chaque fois c'est à une organisation un
peu plus compliqué avec chaises comme
france donc il me faut le temps de vous
lancer à tout ça et on va être bon
pascal et châtel et machin truc voilà
c'est plus compliqué techniquement et
comme n'y a pas de régie derrière danse
a atteint certains points de complexité
une fois que ces lives il faut aller
toucher quelques petits trucs c'est pas
très compliqué mais voilà ça me fait
perdre les quelques premières secondes
de stream d'un autre côté j'ai envie de
dire c'est pas le plus important
j'ai réussi à mettre les calmes des
joueurs tout ça je les fait en amont et
ça devrait bientôt partir je vais
attendre les premiers les premières
personnes dans le chat pour un peu
discuté alors on va faire quelque chose
d'un peu spécial aujourd'hui j'ai réussi
à avoir l'autorisation j'espère que ça
va tenir
may hamm et de se mettre un peu en pause
du speech s junior au moment où maxime
jouera pas ce que je vais quand même
argumenté que l'on préfère voir maxime
que que ça rime contre tang
après j'espère que vous êtes d'accord
avec moi mais en gros entre des joueurs
de second plan et notre mvl nationale du
coup l'indien alors on en l'indien c'est
sarine et le russe est apparu ce
pourquoi il a écrit russie à il n'a pas
changé le titre sur twitch à cause du
moa à cause du mot ça c'est terrible
c'est terrible il faut que je change le
titre est en fait le mot sarin il a pas
prix au kg
je le sais que sur certains mots ya des
problèmes et
et donc il faut que je change de titre
faut que je change je fais le changement
il m'a pas pris le mot il a dû prendre
ça pour gaz sarin et à et du coup ça
doit être un mot interdit le piège par
avance a été changé de toute façon le
titre réel et pas forcément plus vendeur
alors attendez je vais ok on va trouver
les joueurs et on va suivre alors je
sais pas si quand on observe comme ça ça
re match direct on va suivre du côté des
blancs bon alors c'est toujours le
format très très longues disputes us
donc on a le temps bon c'est à une
variante arbitres du gambit dame alors
souvent à l'idée en fait que le pion ses
seins qui fait un blocage et que les
noirs peuvent pas réussir à jouer cinq
pour casser la structure
je vais en profiter pour éteindre mon
téléphone
pour pas avoir de motif
donc ça c'est bon ça c'est bon ça c'est
bon ça c'est salut loach s dans le tchad
ont comme cette petite position avec le
pion sait si ce qui est quand même bien
placé dans le camp adverse qui bloque le
fou ces huit normalement faire un gros
en gros cinéma entre guillemets avec
andrew teng macha un très fort sur
internet je pense qu'il va juste se
faire écraser on verra mais un jeu mais
andrew teng loin loin loin derrière ya
le sarine alors après ce camp un plus un
il va pouvoir revenir ou un peu sur sur
les ait note en tout cas j'espère une
victoire de sarine a titre perso dans le
sens où en fait c'est un vrai joueur
d'échecs quoi il joue pas que sur la
vitesse de souris et sur les petites
magouilles est donc j'espère j'espère
quand même victoire de sarine la dans
l'ouverture il m'est déjà une grosse
pression sur son adversaire et on va
voir ce que ça donne
il va y avoir un fou qui va arriver en
d3 qui a valu en jeu 5 un petit rock
écoutez la position semble assez
agréable côté blanc alors est ce qu'il
réfléchit à faire flamber sarrail doit
il doit réfléchir à fouler 5
ouais voilà pour faire vous prendra
quatre donc c'est ça qui calculait fou
des 3rocs dames 2 a assuré déjà un un
avantage mais c'est vrai que si on peut
prendre enfin en gros tu penses à sa'a
fou à quatre portes sur surface histoire
dont vous prend 1,4 on empêche de roque
et c'est peut-être désagréable mais il a
dû calculer dame prend 1,4 fou prend b5
dame prend b5 et il a dû se dire bon bah
peut-être des tours à 5 machin je recule
il se passe rien j'ai eu honte j'ai
honte de plus j'ai ils vendent plus sur
la colonne à et je suis très très bien
tu as ton petit yvan colonna était très
très bien donc fou b5 avec qui des fous
prend à 4 ans peut-être un coût qui peut
être malin ceccarelli e4 avec l'idée dit
ok tu peux pas faire dame prend pour le
moment et quand tu fais le fou prend je
fais fou à 6 et si tu fais rock
je vous fous à 6 quand même et j'essaye
de jouer sur un truc ici
mais alors après ce que dame prend 1,4
marche prend b5 dame prend des 5
à première vue il n'y a pas de problème
pour les blancs ça a l'air d'être juste
un vrai pion de plus donc j'ai envie de
vous dire ça sent quand même assez bon
pour teng cette position donc on va on
va voir on va voir où ça nous mène mais
teigne me paraît quand même ça se
passera bien pour ta n'y a rien pour ni
à la sarine on va avoir un no sign qui
peut vraiment envie de faire enfler le
score dans ce match
alors est-ce que le hosting à marcher
sur ma chaîne perso c'est ce que je vais
aller vérifier pendant que tu n y
réfléchit en effet tour à 5 alors
d'accord torah 5
il veut forcer fou prend 1,4 et
peut-être joué x 6 en ce moment là après
comme je vous dis hein c'est un vrai
pion de plus question c'est si ce qui
est bien l'hébergement qui marche
donc ça c'est quand même une bonne
nouvelle et désolé pour la caméra qui
sera peut-être pas toujours bien cadré
mais ils m'ont mis une caméra très
grande donc ça ça me force à faire un
grand zoom parce que j'ai pas une caméra
grand angle est donc un petit peu un
petit peu compliqué je suis un peu
proche de mon écran avec avec le micro
radio entre guillemets avec b 5e fou qui
va repartir en c2 ma foi ça devrait ça
devrait rapidement faire le point côté
je vérifie en parallèle ainsi tout
marche bien ça doit faire le point côté
sarine
écoutez fous ces deux mâts
les noirs qui ont juste pour le moment
font une fougue partie assez assez
médiocre 1 après ça va jouer pour
larnack mais c'est pas forcément les
échecs que l'on apprécie le plus
je trouve pas le truc ça marche
forcément écouté ça est ce que ça marche
l'autre côté du stream les juniors ouais
ben écoute c'est sympa après le seul
truc un peu dommage c'est que les
matches soient très long voilà il va
juste faire à quatre ils vont à quatre
baies 3 es fou détroit brive a tenté des
pièges après oui le seul petit regret de
cette compétition c'est des matches très
longs mais ça on a j'ai envie de dire
malheureusement malheureusement
l'habitude de deux matchs au format aa
rallonge quoi je suis pas arrivé à 2008
hier soir tard gaël j'étais pas loin
ah si je stream est pas je serais
remonté c'est sûr mais en stream ans
avec la fatigue accumulée
c'est dur je vois pas le problème après
à quatre baies 3 food et 3 fautes faire
gaffe côté nihal sarine 2 pas alors à ok
à 4 il veut faire b3 fou prend b3 et x 6
ok c'est ça son idée comme souvent des
ressources tactique et donc le calcul
c'est fou des trois fous b 4 échecs roi
eux deux mais bon il va y avoir dame
prend b3 tour d un airois f1 ça a l'air
de naviguer correctement pour les blancs
mais on comprend à quoi y réfléchit
c'est pas alors non finalement blue
world ils ont décidé de ne pas
raccourcir non non ils raccourcissent
que les que les qualifications où ils
font des matches qui durent entre une et
deux heures suivant la fin entre 1h15 et
1h45 suivant la durée des parties
donc il ya un très bon format que moi à
titre personnel trouver le meilleur
format pour moi des matchs de 3h30 4h
c'est trop long que ce soit des échecs
du cycliste du tennis ça ça doit rester
dans le cadre de l'exceptionnel dans des
matches dans des finales dans des matchs
très serrés dans des tournois
particulier après je vois je trouve que
4 3h30 4h pour l'attention d'un
spectateur ou même vous même pour moi
c'est celle ondes se projeter sur un
truc qui va annoncer d'avancées va durer
quatre heures après ma foi non c'est pas
ouf pour les viewers c'est pas ou pour
les gens qui commentent et c'est pas ouf
pour les joueurs je sais qu est ce
quelque chose j'ai honnêtement beaucoup
de mal à comprendre mais écoutez c'est
comme ça on va encore sap et des machins
comme nakao iphone pas la saison
dernière on n'a pas eu de chance sur les
quinze matches de ce pitch est je pense
qu'on en a allez au bas mot 8,6 ont été
complètement inintéressant 3 4 qui ont
été moyens et je crois deux trois qui
ont été bons donc en fait c'est un ratio
de 2 sur 15 qui était vraiment
intéressant est vraiment avec huit
matchs à sens unique qui avait aucun
intérêt
c'est vrai que c'est un peu famélique
mais bon ça fait ça fait quatre ans que
ça dure et ça change pas donc il doit y
avoir un intérêt qui m'échappe 1 voilà
après c'est une interrogation que je me
pose
on en revient toujours au même un
spectacle c'est environ deux heures a
oui c'est deux heures maximum un
spectacle c'est c'est le format
d'absolument fin de quasiment tous les
sports après quand j'organise des event
comme comme je lé fais là la partie qui
tourne un peu je sais pas pourquoi il
n'a pas joué le truc avec un 4 mai à
s'arrimer un truc qui lui a pas plu la
partie qui tournait un peu maintenant
égalité matérielle bon ça va être chaud
mais ça peu de temps à la pendule c'est
peut-être al'avantage de tongs oui non
les joueurs n'apprécient pas les matchs
non plus en fait c'est pas apprécié du
public pas apprécié des joueurs pas très
apprécié des joueurs en tout cas avec
qui j'ai pu discuter et c'est pas
forcément ouais je sais quelque chose
j'ai du mal à comprendre mais on vous
avez vu le format que j'ai fait lorsque
moi j'aime bien dire lorsque moi c'est
ça met un peu en avant genre le mec avec
un ego un melon démesuré mais lorsque
j'ai organisé un événement la semaine
dernière on essaie de faire des matchs
avec 17 avec des des retours possibles
et puis bon coin joueur qui est plus
fort le match s'arrête rapidement pour
bon pour marc de maintenir quelque chose
d'intéressant d'excitant sur quelques
jours et pas que ça dure des mois comme
comme à chaque fois là là je pense moi
pour un mois on a quinze matches en un
mois de 4 heures donc ça me paraît assez
énorme d'avoir d'avoir autant d'heures
de compétition après après c'est comme
ça et + 3 secondes un pur sarine qui
c'est nîmes à l'otan un niall sarine ça
sent le gaz là dans cette première
partie qui décide tout tenté cavaliers
finissent non il est mal autant le
joueur indien il va falloir à tout prix
accélérez face à andrew teng c'est très
dangereux de cette missive à l'otan
surtout pour pas très bien joué les
tours bessette l'entourent c1 oliva il
va il va tomber
or il n'a aucune chance là même avec
l'une secondes par coup ça va être très
sale aujourd'hui en ce qu'il peut se
passer on va voir si ça arrive dès la
première partie réussi à à jouer vite
avec et b4 il s'en prend à qui et
prendre des cinq une vraie menace pour
ces cinq jouer tempo a bien joué de la
part du pingouin la tour qui par angers
1 tour 17 échec intermédiaire à tours
détours cette incroyable près move
piégeurs de deux tanks qui était un coup
qui était très mal joué mais il a dû
voir qu'ils allaient primove tour g1
c'est là où il est forte c'est qu'il
fait exprès très mal joué parce qu'il
sait qu'il a été obligé de près move et
ce à un énorme point fort c'est
insupportable à jouer après pour moi
sont pas des échecs mais mes seins c'est
autre chose c'est plus du gaming
alors là est-ce qu'il va tenter cette
course et 6 soit pour gagner un peu de
temps pour ces cinq échecs retour ces
six retours c5 faut qu'ils se méfient et
va pouvoir arrive pas nul hein teigne
mais il va être obligé
ouais il va être obligé mais c'était
très bien joué le tour le tour aux 7
parce qu'en fait ça ça faisait pas sans
ce vraiment de retour 7 et donc ça
oblige est quand même plus ou moins
feintes étaient sûrs qu'il allaient près
move tour g1 parce que c'était la
variante qui faisait le plus sens et ça
a été très bien joué on voit les
qualités de joueur de bullet sur
internet de la part de textes contre on
peut pas faire à en partir elle quand on
plus l'habitude de jouer sur un
échiquier où qu'on a plus appris avec un
échiquier
on ne peut pas on peut pas le faire la
dame en 1 je pense pas qu'ils aient
damman prises en un alors le problème
qu'ils aillent et prend des cinq ici
marchandise c'est que ton roi serait
emprise et ça ça fait toujours très très
mal ça fait toujours très très mal
manouche l'ouverture qui se passe on est
côté pingouins mais pas moins vrai que
joue contre gotham chef faut organiser
un match plein gotham chef très
important pour voir si l'adoption du
gotan chaise par le pingouin assez
intéressant sakho match parce que c'est
ça qu'il faut organiser sur trois heures
et demi d'opposition qui doit être
encore théorique alors y est on est on
est une dame f 5 1 qui était intéressant
qui est théorique d'un prize cinq pions
pour avec 5 et la finale en fait les
noirs vont venir contrôler des 5es 4es
les blancs réussissent pas à faire
parler les les pions doublé non mais je
suis très heureux en vrai honnêtement
c'est une belle affiche
le voilà l'unique défaut c'est que si tu
te projettes sur cette affiche je suis
dit on va avoir une heure trente de
match ça va être intense
je suis au taquet à 200% je me dis c'est
génial quand tu le dis au moment où je
m'assieds ça va durer quatre heures
honnêtement
sais tu vois j'ai envie de dire voilà si
on compare à d'autres choses de la vie
de même même pour d'autres choses ça me
paraît un peu long tu vas quatre heures
tu vois ça je me dis ça va être un peu
long quoi et donc là voilà c'est un peu
la même chose du coup je suis un peu
fatigué d'avant si tu vois mais bon on
espère un beau match le truc c'est qu'on
se réveille du coup après 1h30 2h de ma
3 2 heures de match si c'est serré comme
ça on commençait un peu à se réveiller
mais bon on a déjà roulé pendant pendant
90 km on peut être un peu dans le dur
dans les dernières ascensions
mais bon là ce qui est bien c'est qu'à
20h on va pouvoir switcher sur mvl ça va
être cool un arrêt ce qui fait d'alger
six séismes et en ré mesdames jécistes
des cavaliers h4 qui vont re d'esquire
par an à cinq est ce qu'il va carrément
en c2 pour aller toucher b3 est ce que
finalement c'est pas la classe b 3 où il
serait le plus en sécurité
il va il va il va toucher v3 failli
touch v2 il chatouille b 2 et touch v3
ndiaye jour à 20h 21h30 et 23h et on ira
et on ira donc on suivra le match
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient
un score serré et après on filera tout
de suite sur ma chaîne perso pour la
pour la fin du match pour la fin des
parties de mvl krikor qui abonnés burly
sandales à sa chaîne ouais donc là j'ai
jeté un oeil quand même sur le chrono on
sait jamais non eh bien il reste bien
une heure quinze de section 5 + 1 c'est
terrible j'ai eu un espoir puis
peut-être j'aime à lui peut-être non en
un an
je n'ai pas mal lu
je n'ai
mal lui j'ai même très bien lui alors
attendez en portugais il a fait dame ces
deux îles et changent pas alors il
protège le pion b21 aussi qui est
attaquée fin à tacler peut-être attaqué
après c'était une grosse question sur un
fou comme eux trois est ce qu'on pouvait
vraiment sans paraître ce pion mais bon
et des cavaliers à cinq fins et très
compliqué en fait donc il a décidé de
faire damas 2 et 2 et de se blinder bien
je suis tourné en fait en russie ne
retransmette pas le match je suis en
train de regarder en face à feytiat que
nous qui est qui retransmettront corner
on est là je juge atteint enfin cesser
par curiosité pourquoi nous on
retransmet les autres non c'est par la
question reste entière sait dans quel
contexte le mv le tournoi amical sur
internet des chèques 960 mémé tournoi
amical quand même hein
donc damas deux mais comment est ce que
niall va continuer
avoir réfléchi longuement prélat plein
d'options il a kara lieu 4 est une
option et à peut-être eu 5 et une idée
il adam b3 quand même cavalière à 5 pour
jouer cavalli b3 le pingouin et à la
fatigue aidant la caméra on pourrait le
troll et lui écrire tu es fatigué gros
noms ou c'est moi ça a l'air d'être un
pingouin qui n'a pas dormi depuis un
moment sur la banquise nom ou c'est moi
enfin cédric question ce qui n'a pas
l'air fatigué nerveusement fragile leurs
besoins mais toujours comme ça oui mais
il a tout le temps fatigué en fait je
travaille trop le pingouin bien faire
trop de choses il dort pas à ces normes
il ay là il a vraiment l'air fatigué non
vraiment là je regarde la caméra fait de
côté parce que moi pour moi elle est à l
est pas au même endroit que vous mais il
ya une petite mine le pingouin
alors après c'est pas parce qu'il ya
tout le temps la même tête qui n'a pas
une tête on le sent on le sent un peu
exténué n'en manque de fer proches le
sens plein anémie le pingouin
il a pas l'air de il respire pas la
forme il respire pas la forme le
pingouin et alioua il a des petits yeux
ouais t'as l'impression que non mais
même globalement après faute et il a le
teint très pâle tui ma vie m'a pas l'air
bien un manque de magnésium way le
pingouin il va falloir il va falloir un
peu des parts
sarine par contre il est chaud patate
enfin fou sarine il a l'air plein
d'énergie sarine a l'air vraiment plein
de plein d'énergie il est il est tout
feu tout flamme la main en pingouin
manque de sommeil ou manque de magnésium
ah non moi je pense un peu départ et ça
repart un pur pour andrew teng
ouais ça rime il a du gaz ouais ouais
ouais on sent que on sent qu'il peut
placer une attaque à tout moment
ils n'arrêtent pas de s'étirer nan mais
il se réveille mais tu sens que tu sens
qu'il va placer une attaque mais ça
arrive ça va pas du tout tant que la
rendre où ça va pas du tout
maintenant ça craint c'est un français
qui n'a pas l'arrêt viable ouh là là où
la lave nous le vrai qui comprend pas le
second degré il a un train de retard
des fois qu'on s'est trop biousse ne pas
faire remarquer peut peut peut faire
partie d'un trait d'humour
cependant à bout le vrai n'a pas l'air
d'être au niveau les amis
il a l'air blasé fatah l'impression que
soit il en manque de sommeil soit en
manque de magnésium soit dépressif en
fait où les trois mélanger les mines
fait peur en fait
l'air de s'ennuyer wave un ennemi mère
complètement blasé en fait après
peut-être qu'il fait c'est un truc assez
étonnant mais à ta quand même pas mal de
joueurs d'échecs qui joue aux échecs par
habitude qui savent pas quoi faire
d'autre mais en fait ils n'aiment pas
vraiment c'est un truc terrible en fait
c'est un genre de fléau dans les échecs
aime beaucoup de gens qui jouent par
défaut mon cas et des rivaux français 4
1 je vous dis tout de suite
bref trois d'accord donc il veut
empêcher fou prend ses quartiers sur
foot france et cathy veut dame b61
clairement il repart avec la dame faut
être trois qui avait prôné de prise d 2
et 2,5
j'adore les noirs parce que le roi blanc
et au centre donc tentatives des changes
de dames du manic la dame repart en
baisse 6 prises de 5 prises de cinq ils
attaquent b2 a ils attaquent payal
cavaliers des rails le roi est fait
enrager de il te dit tu as pas le temps
de m'attaquer
parce que tu peux pas m'attaquer sur
blanc assez pas mettre sa avec les
normes c'est très frustrant et il va
avoir le temps de deux chèques alors
suivons ce qui se passe voyez faire
flouer 2,3 f1 roi g2 bien joué et
intègre vraiment très bien joué la
grosse défense du joueur américain
il joue très il a très très bien défendu
la tour qui va partir en des 8 bat zheng
qui bat tours 17 et 37 à attend pour
preuve cette d'un problème 114 points f5
et on prend et cette dame prend f77 fou
des trois croix jeu suite à des fuites
seimat
et là ça fait 1 0 pour le pingouin
alors on va mettre ces corps avec les
demi j'avais laissé 0 0 alors est ce
qu'on met dans les scores les deux me
poupart les gars c'est un peu la
question
moi j'aime pas mettre les demi point
normalement je met les victoires on aura
un score non officielle mais on va
mettre les victoires au moins on saura
qui a gagné combien de partis on va pas
comptabilisé les nuls on va se faire
notre classement à nous en fait rire de
paix y croit le pingouin ben en fait ils
assez dominé mais je trouve que ça rime
fait une erreur
déjà il boit un truc qui a l'air assez
dégueulasse donc ça c'est une première
erreur qu'il est en train de faire mais
il fait une erreur c'est que il gère mal
son temps sarine
maintenant il faut qu'il faut qu'ils
boivent des boissons de qualité non
moment on aura un score qualitatif dans
l'estuaire faire le truc avec à 5 à 4 je
pense pas un console par mois mais il se
dit pas assez intelligent faire partie
des meilleurs a oui non mais il est très
très loin des meilleurs en vrille fins
et c'est terrible c'est terrible
là ça rime qui doit suer 1 normalement
il est quand même assez lourds favori du
match va se remettre côté blanc je
préfère
bon
il a un peu inversés les coups il a
laissé le fou se développer avant de
faire x 6 à 4 pour pas laisser les
défoulés 5.4 qui avait lieu dans la
partie précédente
il salua marc fans ricky puisque sarine
un futur 27,50 alors possible mais après
il peut très bien finir champion du
monde comme 27 ou 27 20 et caisses et
des classements qui sont pas si
incroyable que ça pour des joueurs
professionnels un j'entends il peut
viser la case 17 parfois
il peut viser la case 17
alors puisque banquiers des joueurs
professionnels labaki était top 10
mondial
s'il vous plaît bach était plus que
joueur professionnel
on dirait qu à l oblique sans fissure
premier tour à dur à dire
je me fais trop léché messenger à ses
manches enfoncé oui c'est mon chant
français mais ses pingouins en anglais
donc on va l'appeler le pingouin ce ping
wind bon moment c'est parti qui manque
un peu de rythme ça s'emballe pas ses
positions assez fermé alors on pourrait
changer en d3 et jouer au foot et ici
c'est un vêtement peut faire food et 600
premiers aussi ça après c'est aux
joueurs de choisir c'est des choix qui
ont qui ont être qu'ils doivent être
faits le pion c6 offre évidemment un
petit avantage aux blancs il ya des cas
et 17 un jour il ya ici un pion ses sept
tombes qui on a quatre être un peu moins
bien mais ça ça doit se tenir quand même
avec les noir sans trop de soucis un
médecin qui l'a quand même vraiment
fatigué 1
mais ils jouent bien écoutez c'est un
style un or là il hésite entre fou prend
1,5 intermédiaire statistiques surtout
reprend 1,6 a accueilli 17 qui peuvent
rodez avec l'idée surtout huit de fer
fou prend des six puis on prend des 6 et
ça peut être très embêtant ça bon il y
aurait qu il prend des six est encore
meilleur que ça ça pourrait être un
problème
il a pris a eu cinq en premier et il
laisse des coups comme fou bessette
mais il veut [ __ ] en f4 fou prend à 8
et peut-être fouquereau 3 puis on prend
2,3 d'un prend 1,8 et son cavalier 4 est
vraiment monstrueux il doit bien valoir
une tour après f5 ya pas assez de
colonne ouverte mais c'est compliqué
hein
il ya peut-être des cas et des 6 kgs ces
quatre dames français si ce qu'ils
peuvent rodez mais la position est quand
même très compliqué les joueurs qui
complique un qui rendent pas dans les
échanges les plus simples et qui
essayent de rentrer dans la variante
optimale les tours prend au monde dans
l'autre chat skype chadli stream aussi
qu'ils discutent ce qui est pas qui a et
17 ans on a un peu regardés ouais ça
marchait mais jamais trop
ouais j'ai quatre mois ce matin mais
magnifique y avait scission on sait qu
il pouvait pas faire et si ces dames
prendre 6 et j'ai ici s'il n'avait pas
envie alors c'est peut-être une petite
concession puisque le fou quand même y
tape là il tape là donc si la dame bien
en g3 regardez pas les blancs peuvent
avoir deux pièces qui combine ensemble
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte de
cette belle géométrie ça fait un genre
de double pierre ou la double pyramide
attention quand même avec avec un hula
attention attention quand même à ce
qu'est en train de faire à ce qu en
train de faire ni à la cif est d'alger 3
ça fait une double pyramide et il le
fait en la double pyramide qui est là et
ça va même beaucoup plus loin parce
qu'il ya une double pyramide et il ya un
genre de de genre de merde en 8es n'en
très dangereux mais le truc c'est que le
x e 5 et supérieur au carré de 8
s'éclaire d'un autre côté la position
est très fermé si les blancs veulent
gagner vont devoir jouer un jour du 4 ou
quoi le cavalier pour arrow jaillir
peut-être en d5
peut-être si tu veux ne rien faire avec
les blancs je pense que tu peux
tranquillement par contre si tu veux
commencer à la gagne et ça peut être
assez dangereux
d'un autre côté c'est difficile de rien
faire parce que c'est pas les noirs qui
serait pas mieux à terme genre avec ubp
et 5 pour penser si ce qui arrive dans
longtemps ouais c'est exactement la
question que je me pose est ce que c'est
pas les noirs qui ont les idées pour
gagner ici la tour qui part en b3 adam
ii ils bloquent mais a eu 5 qui va
arriver je pense c'est noir qui vous le
gain tu penses c'est plutôt fin qui joue
le gain c'est les noirs qui joue la
pression quoi
c'est les noirs qui vous la pression et
c'est les blancs qui souffre légèrement
parce que ce pion ans et si ce qui était
une force pendant un moment de la partie
va devenir une faiblesse va devenir une
faiblesse le roi s'il arrive en un an
des six dans une finale lointaine il
pourra prendre le pion c'est un vrai
problème
donc ouais avantage gérer légère
avantage noirs ici en tout cas on voit
un plan de gains possibles pour les
noirs cependant toujours pareil quand on
essaye de gagner une partie on prend
forcément le risque de se faire contrer
surtout les positions comme ça parce que
j'aurais eu 5 comprend emprise dam des
trois tu commences à orly déchets pas
genre tu fais bon on va dire une
connerie en fait tour à huit voies genre
déjà ça ça peut ça peut ça peut tourner
un truc dangereux avoir après 1 mais ça
peut être dangereux donc il faut il faut
être toujours très méfiants côté côté
noir de 8h trois dames c'est 8 d'accord
alors son plan c'est de mettre la dame
en a 6 et de proposer les changes la
dame pourra repartir d'accord donc niall
qui décide d'envoyer le contre eux je l
ai le droit il va mettre un pion h56
c'était une dame angers 6 qui contrôlera
la case d3 ce qui peut être utile
s'empêcherait dam des trois adverse
2 après les gars mon ascension vallée
2008 n'oubliez pas qu'avec les heures de
stream que je cumule et le fait de jouer
en stream ans je me pénalise quand même
assez grandement pour les rushs comme ça
surtout quand le stream comme ça tous
les jours là je suis à 23 24 25 jours de
de stream consécutifs et du coup je joue
souvent avec de la fatigue accumulée et
je pense sans cela j'aurais 28 30 28 40
c'est vraiment très pénalisant
ce serait 3 buts fixés banon mais
j'aurai ce que je disait jaurès suivant
les périodes entre 30 et 70 points de
plus à peu près là non quand je suis en
période j'aurais pas les 70 points de
plus j'aurais peut-être 28 30
mais bon c'est vraiment pénalisant c'est
évident c'est surtout quand tu enchaînes
beaucoup d'heures de stream tu vois là
ça fait sur les trois quatre dernières
semaines c'est du cdu 40 50 heures de
stream en moyenne plus plus les vidéos
youtube donc ça fait ça fait vraiment
des semaines assez chargé quelque part
même en fait moi je m'étais sarine
favori mais le pingouin joue mieux donc
le pingouin est effectivement à partir
de maintenant favoris oui très
clairement nous sommes tout à fait
d'accord et nous souscrivons à cette
analyse de l'ombre de kiev
et puis on sait si ce qui est faible 1
et 2 nouveaux pains ghuama l'otan est-ce
que tu jouerais autant c'est une strie
mais pas avant je suis raide autre chose
non alors attendez roitg cette dame h 1
il a raté tout reprendre 4 aidé à me
quatre échecs c'est chaud à tour prend
des cinq prises des 5 da me caty la tour
f 5 maintenant il défend bien le pion
f2m il a plutôt mis al sarine l'aï les
cas il est là là on peut le dire que ça
sent le gaz pour lui
roy chain tour g1 allez faut blinder un
tangérois ton g2 copé s'était pas très
bien pensé mais un aa oui d'accord a
bien joué il a pas vus teng prise prise
prise yaya toure là en l'air d'al
tactique et sur pions prend les atours
ses huit échecs wife 7 et dame des sept
matches si on veut maintenir la pression
grosse défense au ses shows légal une
seconde chacun aux ja dame france et 8 k
tu as mérité un pour le pingouin qui
domine est quand même la partie de la de
la tête et des épaules et ça fait 2 0
c'est très étrange parce que c'est celle
sarine est vraiment un
un excellent joueur et le pingouin est
vraiment pas impressionnant on sera peut
être que baky a raté un maton 2 contre
lui mais moi quand je les construis je
trouve vraiment pas impressionnant après
une flaque bien et j'ai du mal à vous
avez du mal à imaginer et à niall sarine
avoir autant de problèmes face à lui
après c'est intéressant simplement si le
match se passe comme ça dans ces
sections là qu'est ce que ça va être un
plus un ou en trois plus un ampli s'il
est vraiment très prenable niall ça rime
pour moi n'est pas dans son match tout
simplement
après peut-être qu'il prend pas la
compétition superbe au sérieux ou
peut-être qu'il a il a pas fait les
choses en sorte d'être en forme en tout
cas il ya un vrai retard à l'allumage
c'est intéressant est ce qu'il va
réussir à revenir à combler l'écart
il ya que deux points d'écart mais il
faut pas qu il
le score enfle et un karim plus des lots
sur tu as comme un c non non c'est
simplement neeraj sarine et simplement
un meilleur joueur globalement mais bon
et je contre qui m vers la 20 heures ça
c'est une excellente question à laquelle
je vais essayer de répondre parce qu'il
y avait pas de quand j'ai regardé à
17h50
il n'y avait pas de d'appariement
annoncé en tout cas je ne pouvais pas
les trouver
pour le moment je vois pas d'appariement
alors peut-être qu'ils sont sortis
quelque part mais je les vois pas pour
le moment donc on ne sait pas par qui ça
commence c'est officiel mission de 960
non pas du tout c'est sur internet après
c'est sympa parce qu'à kasparov mais
c'est pas non plus ah c'est pas non plus
face à une compétition amicale quoi n'y
a pas deux il ya pas vraiment dangereux
si maxime s'est lui-même contre qui joue
en tout cas c'est avec nice à rim pour
le parlement à mon avis enfin voilà pour
moi c'est un résultat surprenant et là
encore je trouve les blancs fiction
quand même agréable il a un petit
avantage des espaces le fou g3 est bien
placé bon après il peut faire dame
cécile couvrir contre attaque maths mais
une nouvelle fois il s'en sort bien
échange de pièces auraient l'avantagé se
passe c'est pas une faute
tu veux dire à quel moment voilée tous
renoncé une colonne ouverte mais bon il
faut bien faire quelque chose avec des
pièces près car lycées 4 c'est une
option aussi évidemment mais bon il a
voulu échanger un cavalier pour pour se
prendre la case de 4 et attaquer avec à
une certaine logique fa les échecs c'est
des grands principes mais bon c'est bien
de faire les grands principes au début
mais après c'est quand même plus
compliqué que ça prayssac à eséka tu
étais une option
est ce que ça peut être bien de jouer
960 pour progresser je pense pas non pas
c'est bien de jouer pour jouer quoi tel
truc accueille ces quatre attaques la
dame des cinq pour clouer d'approuver si
ce temps là je vais m'aider de l'ordi
dix cavaliers 17,1 et ce contre attaque
des 4l elle a réussi à bien se placer
avec les noirs peut-être on peut aller
faire un jeu sur cases noires mais je
vais vous dire à base de dessins clf ou
reculer cavaliers h5 et profiter du pion
à f3 qui affaiblit un tas de cases
noires va pas jouer f4 un sas est un
mystique de ma part mais ça peut être un
vrai problème parce que fouet f2 foiry
vendée 6.5 d'accord en faut toujours
vérifier les tours prend 1,5 à partir de
maintenant
ici ça semble pas marcher peut-être du
coup il va faire un fou des six enfin
quoique peut-être on peut prendre
prendre et faire dame prend dame c5 et
des rêves deux dames e3 pour essayer de
prendre de 5 mais même ça ça commence à
se regarder puisque les quasars sont
faibles
fou des ciseaux 6 1 pour s'octroyer la
case f4 ou g3 pour pour le cavalier
intéressant j'aime bien la position du
joueur indien une nouvelle fois mais il
réussit pas à percer la carapace
d'andrew tels gains depuis tout à
l'heure donc il va falloir réussir enfin
à a gagné une partie comme dirait une
marque anne comme dirait mur tu as puis
une autre c'est un peu la grande théorie
de mur tu as gagné une partie puis une
autre on va voir
il ment fort que toi ce pingouin est il
et il est censé être moins fort mais bon
après après il s'en sort pas ya aussi
fous ces cinq peut-être comme couche en
train de réfléchir pour jouer le clouage
et s'en prendre aux fous mais bon
peut-être juste 3 h 1 et ont fait pas
grand chose au final je pense qu'ils
calculent clairement tout reprend 1,5
ici parce que ça c'est très tentant de
jouer toutes les cases un an avec avec
les flux le foot recasement à lecavalier
regarde quelque chose en même temps
qu'ils jouent il a tout le temps là êtes
et les yeux baissés à oye alors
peut-être regarde la télé en même temps
quoi
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils cèdent pas
dans l'ordinateur food et 6
qui était l'autre courroucé 5 c'est le
truc que tu calcules et puis si tu les
joues pas tu te rabat sur food et 6 il
s'est rabattu sur food et 6 une nouvelle
fois est-ce que c'était une bonne
gestion du temps est alors dur dur de
critiquer puisque ton 35 pouvait faire
très malin mais fou des six
ce que je vois la vague des fois non non
moi je les lui fait don à une époque un
mais mais c'est fini c'est fini
f4 spengler ouais mais henri iv et 1re
caté chiant tu peux pas le fou protège
en f4 donc tu peux pas vraiment le
joueur je le reçois chaque plus qu'à
cliquer chatte il a fait quoi il a fait
tout revin et là ya du cavalier f4 qui
rôde un missile yaka relief 4 qui rôdent
maintenant pour on peut venir attaquer
tous les trucs sur blanc très
intéressant ici vous prend 1,5 d'abord
d'accord pourquoi pas c'est plutôt à un
coût intéressant ça va reprendre 5 de la
tour ou du pion
je pense plutôt de la tour pour essayer
d'échanger du matériel d'un autre côté
quand tu prends la tour il faut regarder
les dames c'est un échec cavaliers f1
mais ça semble plus logique simplement
dames c'est ça qui va rentrer damev deux
des quatre dames f2 ici serait le coût
que je jouerai ça attaque ici ça prépare
cavaliers f4 well as là il va revenir au
score au score niall
mesdames damev deux têtes il fera dame
ces trois cavaliers f4 fouet fin ce qui
va essayer de défendre comme ça des
quatre qui donne envie et partir avec la
dame là haut tu as l'impression que ça
va mater mais parfois ça m'atteint pas
ces trucs là il a commencé par cars et
les f4 alors ça change pas grand chose
après fouet f1 annonce ce soir tony
stark une fois que une fois que c'est
fini on va dire masri sur vitry malala
le match mais bon sur un petit peu
épuisé 4h02 commentaire d'un match ça ça
tue en fait ça tue non mais combien les
cas là il est déjà à 18h50 comme ça le
temps passe ça passe plutôt vite temps
passe comme les voitures allaient fouet
faim ces trois voire quatre jours
d'affilée comme ça aujourd'hui demain
après demain et lundi autant dire que
lundi soir il va y avoir 15 matches en
un mois un de toute façon autant dire
que ça va faire du bien quand ça va
s'arrêter à cinq
banner puis solide mais je pense qu'il
faut se garder des options de dames 7 et
d'aller jouer là-bas près ça fait super
peur mais il est de nouveau en train de
le retourner j'ai l'impression parce que
à mais c'est pas moi qui ai mal autant
pardon ouais dame ces trois là il veut
quoi il veut dame csn j'imagine je
pensais que les dames c'est cet état me
prend bessette
je pensais qu'il allait tenter un truc
actif puisque aurait pu on va arriver en
d3 et là il y là j'ai l'impression que
le pingouin elle est vraiment dans le
dur
ok il faut jouer tempo fou prend un
choix de voir cavaliers ou karachi magie
noire tempo bien joué ouais il joue là
il joue très très bien le pingouin bon
il est tombé mais les quelques coups de
défense qu'il a joué dans une position
quasiment impossible alors après sa
paire d un mais mais c'est franchement
bien
parce que le format est bon bah comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure pour moi c'est
beaucoup beaucoup trop long après ça
reste mon avis hein ça joue à la vitesse
là mais ça rime qui a une position quand
même bien meilleure je trouve que tang
dans tous ses détails t-notes il est
plus fort
là encore on ait l'impression dans une
position quasiment injouable il réussit
dans le death note à à quasiment
remonter ce qui est quand même assez
assez incroyable alors à mettre à jour
le score ça fait 2-1 et s'est du coup la
première victoire pour sarine dans ce
match non mais particulièrement bons en
défense 1 particulièrement des bons en
défense le pingouin dans ce match il
réussit à trouver de très belles
ressources
après ça avec beaucoup le prennent pour
un peintre un c'est pas faux
[Musique]
mais parce que il te semble pas
honnêtement il semble pas si fort que 5
ans quand tu vois c'est parti ou quoi
mais il trouve beaucoup de ressources
donc ils échangent et il va vouloir dan
17 et peut-être dame f5 couffo h3
houphouet 5la les noirs ont égalisé un
fou prend b2 ça va reprendre en b2 dame
c8 tout à fait jouable aussi il va faire
foi je trois dames f5 peut-être dame f5
maintenant une tête piquée qui va venir
en c5 en effet fouache 3 arrive il va il
va échanger les fous
mais en tant qu il est vraiment vraiment
fort un timing est vraiment fort c'est
vraiment un excellent joueur
c'est vraiment un excellent joueur en
blitz sur ce qu'ils montrent après c'est
vrai comme que je trucs pas très correct
qu'il n'est pas très technique en partie
longue ou sur le fond de jeu il ne
paraît pas impressionnant mais en blitz
là il est là vraiment les qualités quoi
tant que fournisseur taille n'aura
jamais une carrière de rien du tout il
sera jamais top 100 mondial
méambly de sur internet il est fort là
c'est vraiment vu sur ses premières
parties surtout sur à sur ses qualités
en défense comme je vous dis là il a
montré un sacré niveau de jeu quand il
fait le damel 5 dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure
c'est un petit nice 1 à 4 est faible on
peut dire qu'il est fort si aucune
carrière
pas parce que on essaie de te montre un
match de juniors avec que des gens face
à une compétition il ya personne qui est
vraiment très très fort en vrai en
réalité je crois que tête de série
numéro un signal sarine bon ben moi je
donne pas grand avenir coloniale juniors
c'est moins en moins de 21 ans
je le vois pas rentrer dans le top 10
mondial à titre personnel sarine mais il
est bon mais il m'impressionne pas des
masses
il m'impressionne pas des masses très
fort mais bon enfin tout dépend ce qu'on
appelle force si on appelle fort bond
leader sur internet ni al zain il est
vraiment fort et tango si mais si on
parle du top mondial
enfin j'ai plus le tableau de la
compétition mais y'a aucun joueur qui
m'impressionne vraiment je crois pas que
si routière participent cette année
n'ont en effet qu'un wifi rouge à cette
année attendez je vais essayer de
retrouver à sur mon téléphone
le tableau
alors attendez le tableau il était plus
haut c'est pas le bon tableau alors
attendez c'est ça une tank de l'autre
c'est smirnov ça doit ni bon ça donne ni
peut avoir du talent mais aujourd'hui
n'est pas vraiment fort ikea
martirossian km/heure haye a par am qui
peut être bien vision que c'est bien ça
honnêtement ya ouais je sais pas danser
junior l'a peut-être km/heure peut-être
ça doit ni peut-être prague ananda abdou
s'auto rofl aussi ouais il ya quelques
beaux joueurs on verra peut-être qu'ils
rentreront dans le top 10 mondial et six
pianos j'aime bien aussi niçois jeu mais
bon après pour le mans il confirme pas
tout à fait un bond on était bons jeunes
mais pour le moment c'est parce pas des
joueurs du top mondial
d'ailleurs quand même bête sur cacher on
commencera ici à 20h et puis après dès
que c'est fini on filera on changera de
chaîne après tête on changera un tout
petit peu avant la fin du match si c'est
plié avant la fin
elles étaient 7
bon ça va vers de nouveaux biens pour
les noirs et bien pour le pingouin cette
fois ci ce qui va pouvoir jouer contre
le fou j'ai de jouer cavalier e 500
prend option à f3 il a réussi à mettre
un petit peu en il a réussi à [ __ ] la
m beaucoup de pions sur blanc affaiblir
le roi finalement et les blancs ont pas
réussi à faire beaucoup d'efforts sur
l'ale dame ça assez sympa comme position
pour les noirs ça c'est un peu mieux
après il ya aussi les tours qui ont été
doublés je pense qu'ils qui switch un
peu nihal sarine la en mode je vais
aller essayer de faire une petit nul 1-1
entre ces 5
j'y croyais pas du tout et prend ses 5
ça paraissait pas être le coup de
l'année cinq dons qui menace qu'elle
prend des trois protégés
après il peut prendre une fois prendre
et à il peut pas faire tourner des huit
autour des 7 pour le moment il ne peut
pas prendre
est-ce que ça ça peut être une idée
prise prises et f5
le truc c'est que je veux jouer sur le
fait qu'il ya des kf3 avec une surcharge
sur e1
c'est ce qui va faire et f5 et f5
intéressant
ce kf5 sur pure francky et price 3 plus
pro f 3 tours prend un tour prend un
tour prise 1 dames f3 iliad a mis 8 mata
c'est peut-être ça le problème
ouais non f5 qui marchait pas aussi bien
que je le pensais donc il est parti mais
la tour 11 6
dommage je n'étais pas loin d'eux
d'avoir un gros truc donc tout réussi
s'il veut quand même continuer la tac
avec tours h6 éventuellement hk ton g6
et il va mettre sous pression s'il fait
ça mais ton qui est le pion h4 et qui
joue pour g6 en fait il met sous
pression h
il met sous pression f j'ai aimé quand
même beaucoup de pions sous pression et
ses cinq tours avec 6 cas et 17 mai donc
il ay là il a réussi à ramener son
cavalier en jeu alors pourquoi est ce
qu'il n'est pas parti surtout rage sis
racheté ce paraissait logique quand même
ce que tout réussit ce qui est des sept
le problème c'est qu'il a il a peut-être
un point f3 ici à il a peut-être par f3
mais ça rime qui a dû calculer dame eu
deux bons jeux le clouage et la prise du
cavalier reste plus beaucoup de temps on
va rester sur le direct à pitre watches
qui a eu cinq dames 5
ouais ce cavalier 17 qui était bien joué
trois y avait le dames 2 c'est ce qu'a
raté c'est ce qu'a raté pingouin et là
ça tourne un peu hein c'est plutôt
maintenant sarine qui a pris le dessus
tactique celle inverse en fait tout à
l'heure c'était ça rime qui avaient des
positions et qui se faisait magouilles
et maintenance et pingouins qui à
l'époque guy de position et qui se fait
magouiller et c'est vrai qu'on voit
quand même une différence avec le top
mondial
c'est vrai que les joueurs du top
mondial tu peux rarement laissé un tel
écart de position quand ils ont
l'avantagé mais il ne lâche plus leur
proie et olaya tourcoing et à ce niveau
là ça fait encore des erreurs et ça
laisse encore les proies s'échapper en
tout cas ça fait 2-2 niall sarine qui
égalise avec un scénario de match qui
ressemble pas vraiment à ce que à ce que
je m'imaginais mais quand même on a
on a le joueur indien qui finalement
revient à la marque égalise
il revient au score et bois un petit peu
de café ou un chocolat ouais mais sur
pareil quand à des positions compliquées
et difficiles à jouer
les dames en un ton ben tu s'imposerait
sa théorie oui c'est important pour
sarine de gagner une partie pour en
gagner une autre vraiment du café
laquelle à potins il doit bien avoir 20
ans andrew teng il a bien 20 ans andrew
teng
je vais vous dire ça tout de suite il
est né en 99 donc il a 20 ans il va
avoir 21 ans le 29 novembre
oui bah c'est un c c'est un adulte un
bail est encore en juniors mais en vrai
c'est un homme un déjà hier bien endormi
calme il a l'air trés endormi
il a l'air bien endormi ça rime qui a
plus alors que ça rime il est tard dans
la soirée puisque aux côtés de tongs
il ya quoi il doit avoir il est je sais
pas où il est basé mais il doit être
ouais ça doit être le matin et moi je
joue beaucoup mieux le matin et côté
sarine il doit être tard il donnera à
voir quoi trois quatre heures de
décalage avec l'inde doit être vraiment
tard dans la nuit quoi ils adorent du
malade c'est aussi peut-être ça qui
explique les difficultés 1,2 de niall
il ya plus que quatre heures de décalage
avec l'argent par contre ces six heures
et peut-être six heures là n'a plus tôt
c'est twitter
alors après ce qu'il a en en jan sainz
aussi une question il était en europe
landert on aurait donc ces trois heures
trente c'est bien ce que je disais quand
même probablement en inde avec toutes
les histoires de cow vider tout c'est
vrai moi je trouve que c'est un
désavantage
je préfère largement jouer à 11 heures
midi plutôt qu'à 22h 23h mais bon après
c'est peut-être un goût personnel mais
j'ai l'impression d'être beaucoup plus
l'inférieur de pas fait rage 6 à cause
de quelques points aux six de reprendre
sisters point aussi si on prend aussi ce
fou pranger 6 am et à lecavalier ici qui
en l'air à la fin donc on peut le jouer
pour le moment si on en a envie
oui je trouve que c'est un gros avantage
de 11 heures midi par rapport à 22h 23h
je trouve après vous pendant fin moi
j'ai l'impression qu'on préfère le soir
on a un qu'on pense avoir plus
l'habitude nanani nanana mais
l'impression d'avoir le cerveau beaucoup
plus frais à 11 heures du mat d'être
vraiment beaucoup plus virevoltant
comparé à 22 heures ou à je trouve que
moi je ferai les moins productifs le
soir en général mais bon on est plus
tranquille s'il ya moins de gens qui
appellent mais on est on est moins
productif je trouve
ça dépend du rythme de chacun oui oui
sûrement
en tout cas pour moi j'ai l'impression
qu'entre après faut pas que je joue à
quatorze heure belge à l'escrimé défaut
en début d'après-midi joue mal puisque
je dors aussi ceux des heures où je dors
normalement ouais c'est sûr qu'on est
plus productif enfin pour moi c'est sûr
qu'on doit être plus productif le matin
j'essaie de dormir après le day sera pas
remplie aujourd'hui j'ai moins eu le
temps
j'encaisse des grosses journées j'ai pu
dormir que une demi heure je le sens pas
c'est quoi je le sens passé voilà je
serai bien une petite sieste quoi tu ap
pouze la cc se prépare déjà pour faire
la sieste mais je sens que je n'ai pas
fait par contre
c'est moins le tour de france et nikkei
mais bon grosse étape aujourd'hui grosse
étape mais surtout sur des matches longs
comme ça parce que le match dure 3h30 4h
et sur un match de 3h30 4h j'ai
l'impression que je jouais de 21h à
minuit et demi une heure du matin c'est
beaucoup plus dur que de jouer de 11h à
15h je trouve pas ce que tu quand tu
tape dans tes réveil le soir tu es
beaucoup plus fatigué je fatigue plus
vite le soir peut-être sur un effort
court ça change pas grand chose voire
même tu serais mieux le soir autant
autant sur un effort long je dirais
c'est compliqué pour moi après un prêt
et pendant tout un chacun
toujours cet avantage des espaces pour
le pingouin
on va voir le pingouin qui bâille le
pingouin qui veut dormir mais il va
falloir encore joué il a quoi il est
encore et encore deux heures et demie de
match aller gagné qu'à au paraguay ça se
voit il est vraiment fatigué il a les
yeux rouges tellement ils se disent
lésés su avec talent ils se les gratte
avec les mains c'est l'enfer ce genre de
compet way pour les joueurs aussi ca ca
mais la paix rhdp prend c4 et c5 mais
pour les joueurs aussi c'est dur pour
les joueurs aussi c'est compliqué la
france est que les fervents du pion et
ses jouets pour ses 5 après c'était pas
clair il y avait des sacrifices de
qualité des machins c'est le premier en
convient c'est un honneur de jeu cet
échec c'est ça faire 3h45 de jeu en tout
avec du 5 + 1 pendant une heure et demie
du 3 + 1 pendant une heure et si tu en
avais pas déjà marre encore une
demi-heure de bullet après et avec
dépose enfin en gros c'est à dire 3
heures 45
ouais je pense qu'il veut jouer pour le
cumul des menaces sur des 5-6 f7 la
diagonale blanche le pion à 6 en fait je
pense qu'il veut jouer un peu sur sur
ces deux sur ces deux problèmes
éventuels ah oui c'est long et en plus
sur a15 match aller en un mois je vous
préviens tout de suite ça va être très
long je crois qu'on a l'habitude avec
les compagnies à ce point comme on
al'habitude de choses très très longue
on n'en peut plus à la fin mai mais ça
recommence tout le temps quand même
après j'en connais une compétition plus
courte le bullet championship mâcon va
se retaper un speech s adultes qui va re
durer autant de temps je crois que ce
sera tout pour cette année
donc on va commencer le stream vers la
fin oui peut-être commencer le stream
après deux heures de jeu parce qu'en
plus le 1 + 1 généralement la fin le 5 +
1 en fait en général à la fin de la
cadence hier un ou deux points d'écart
max et en vrai ça ne joue pas du tout là
dessus là c'est la taz en une grosse
heure et demie de match avec la pause et
où en gros ça use
1h45 cousinard 50 l'épreuve la première
50 ou en fait il se passe pas grand
chose quoi c'est pas là dessus que ça
joue il n'ya pas cavalier pro-russe ici
si je regardais alors dit hannon la dame
mais repasse en d2 pardon je l'avais je
voyais tout à l'heure en sur une autre
case sur la la taupe qui comme d'hab et
à l' inverse de ce que fait tout le
monde s'il aime bien la écoute tu peux
pas déjà si tu peux quitter et revenir
et tout ça c'est que tu aimes pas trop
c'est quand même quelque chose tu
regardes de a à z un tube à d'autres
regards et ce soir je fais de la pub à
ta pas forcément fait de la pub pour le
truc le plus intéressant un tony stark
tam détroit ici en fait déjà les mauvais
pions double au centre et d'amd trop en
fait ces coûts puisque tu attaquant à
six bombes et 4 c cool aussi parce que
tu protèges le pion à ce que sa section
dam des trois est peut-être tout
reprendre un tour prendre un dame prend
1,5 et maintenant le cavalier va partir
en c2 et en os 3 pour s'en prendre aux
pions des 5 ou cavaliers ces deux dames
des 3% prendra si ses protégés b4 ouais
c'est bien joué
même si ça fait retour à ccr bien pour
les blancs sas histoire mais il ya plus
de temps à il ya quatre secondes contre
deux les gars et le pingouin ouais c'est
très bien mais là il va enchaîner les
coups tempo assez bizarre là il perd un
peu de temps à essayer bien jouer dam
des trois à l'échangé tour c'est 8
je pense une petite tour ans et 8 là il
fait très très mal
carrillo 2 qui est étranger 3 ça va être
jouée à aimer le fouet fuite qui sort
plus il prend 1,4 il revient c'est bien
joué ils empêchent pouces et 3 il va
mettre le pion g4 il va monter le roi
henri iv et fait qu'elle et ses 2 pour
tous et si ce n'était pas forcément le
plus pratique à mais réussi à revenir et
il allait il à yvan qui part assez bien
joué il n'y a pas de tours à 3 et là il
prend et à cette arrivée à retour d un
roi de deux tours ici mes tours c'est
cette baie 5b 6b 7b 8 c'est imparable et
le pingouin qui reprend l'avantagé qui a
sorti une bonne game 1 qui a dominé en
vrai du début jusqu'à la fin
le bc la caméra ce sera mieux le
pingouin qui reprend le dessus
kiabi est bien sortie de l'ouverture
pardon et qui remporte cette partie
bon écouter mais rejoue le petit b3 four
b2 franchetto il reste une vingtaine de
minutes dans cette cadence à rs 2 ou 3
partie ça dépend comment ça finit
je vais aller checker le chrono officiel
histoire d'être bien sûr que nous dit le
chrono officiel le chrono officiel du 17
minutes 40
partant de l'as vu que les parties son
nom il devrait avoir deux parties
j'imagine un franc l'appelle le pingouin
c'est son pseudo un vêtement sur
internet en doutaient n'y le pingouin
donc c'est son pseudo match plutôt
agréable pour le moment les milieux de
jeu un peu un peu un peu serré et ça
joue souvent on nous ait note à la
famille al zain qui aurait vraiment
intérêt à accélérer un peu le rythme et
il en a peut-être pas les moyens
bon là tout est possible on peut faire
[ __ ] 5 on peut faire rock on peut
faire qu'elle prend des deux frères f5
fort gary cahill et h4
non
qui prendrait deux jouables rock jouable
tout est jouable en fait savoir ce que
tu veux faire du pacifique à laquelle ça
la compétition alors c'est le premier
tour c'est un quart de finale dans sa 8e
de finale et à ses joueurs sont en
huitièmes de finale
c'est le premier match d'ouverture de la
compétition il va y en avoir huit sur ce
même format
ces quatre hier de sortir sur mes deux
ouvertures le pingouin bah écoute il a
eu des grosses difficultés rouve en tout
début de match on avait l'impression que
et qui passent un sale quart d'heure
dont l'ouverture est finalement depuis
la troisième partie depuis la quatrième
partie il sort mieux donc jusqu'à
maintenant il ya eu six parties c'est la
septième donc de la partie 4 5 6 7 donc
là ça fait quatre parties qui sort assez
bien
maintenant je suis d'accord le bullet
ouais c'est pas vraiment un format pas
le format le plus intéressant je suis
assez d'accord avec antonymes
on suivra mvele sur ta chez nous ici sur
les deux mais tu peux mettre ma chaîne
parce que j'ai mise en å sting en fait
du coup et donc quand on arrêtera ici on
partira de l'autre côté mais sans le
sang le hosting ça la magie de twitch tu
peux tu peux aussi citer hosting chaîne
le bfc pour faire du spectacle c'est
vrai leur lit après une nouvelle fois je
trouve qu'on ferait plus de spectacle
avec un match plus courts et sans bullet
mes maîtres du bullet pour un tie break
où quoi tu vois si tu fais 17
le bullet pourrait être un tie break ça
pourrait être une façon moi je suis pour
à concerne le match voulait bien compris
je me répétais plusieurs fois pendant
cette compétition mais ça ça ça me
paraît vraiment très long bon donc là on
peut avoir des pions pendant ou pions
isolé après des princes et 4
top 40 vite le vrai match débute à
wissant 40 minutes on va pouvoir taper
break sur ses trois premiers matches la
chance qu'on a c'est qu'on va pouvoir
zapper
bon on doit quand même regarder ça en
toile de fond mais a mais on regardera
quand même bien maxime surtout surtout
s'ils jouent contre un gros quand tu eu
six ans leur structure faut toujours
faire gaffe de pas se faire enfermer le
fou quant à g et si ceux ci ça peut être
un danger toujours faire attention à
faire acheter ici avec le fou le plan g5
louangé six mois peut faire flouer 4
aussi y'a plus qu'à avaler g5 1 paquet
et des deux
donc c'est une option
c'est une option sur sur dame ses trois
tours c8 c5 v6 jeudi dame c3 parce qu'on
pourrait vouloir jouer les caïds et 2 la
dame sera pas bien placé alors apprendre
plus tenter des quadrillages deux
peut-être avec l'idée de faire f 3 g 4
mai ce sera répondu par un coup comme g5
probablement pour se donner le la case
de recul du fou c'est comme une
opération pour 960 à ton avis aucune
alors pour un événement comme celui-là
au roumain de 3 clairement aucune phase
ils ont peut-être joué un peu des
parties de 960 depuis quelques jours ça
c'est possible mais ils ont rien fait de
plus que ça il n'y a pas eu de camp
d'entraînement ou quoi ça ça reste des
compétitions amicales sur internet après
c'est ça ce qui est sympa aussi
c'est que du coup ça fait une
compétition un peu exhibition n'y a pas
forcément une prépa et donc ça saad
hassar en donne une compétition
intéressante à suivre parce que voilà
c'est pas des événements qu'on a
l'habitude de voir et du coup le format
internet prend tout son sens
le cavaly qui vient naviguait sur les
cases blanches ici alors que les noirs
s'en prennent aux pions des quatre alors
attention parce que ces cinq amendes et
peut être fort un mea bon il y aura du
contrat avec 5 lecavalier qui peut être
bien h5
moi j'aimerais bien la jouer avec les
noirs en fait mais c'est ce que je joue
souvent jour de position avec les normes
un truc comme carénage cinq fois je suis
f4 ça peut poser problème parce que on
peut vite se faire ouvrir le roi après
comme je vous dis parfois on est un peu
biaisé par les positions qu'on a
l'habitude de devoir jouer et de voir
descendre défendre parce que c'est
probablement un peu mieux pour les
blancs mais bon
il y aura firouz a aussi eu dans le dans
le neuf cent soixante ans c'est vraiment
une belle un beau line-up kasparov carax
nmv elle n'a qu'à et fièr ouja et donc
on dit qui reste plus que dix minutes
dans ce segment
ce qui veut dire qu'il va rester cette
partie probablement la suivante
que du lourd est en vrai simple c'est un
beau tournoi
j'ai pas réussi à négocier pouvoir ne
pas commenter celui là malheureusement
enfin ces deux les trois premiers
matches et dont il faut quand même les
commenter gros événement mais mon niveau
quand la partie de mv elle commence tu
pourras faire des allers retours entre
l'un et l'autre des allers retours bien
sûr tu auras y aura un grand talent et
de 2 45 minutes et où elle tient petit
retour de quelques secondes la tiens on
va être le score à jour tiens tu auras
tiens j'ai fait autour de 10 secondes
960 commença à 20h on enverra une partie
donc sur cette chaîne après on switch
ira à partir de la deuxième sur le
stream
on frappe que d aller là pas plus de
retour là n'ont pas aimé aller retour on
m'a pas dit on m'a dit de faire des
allers retours on m'a pas dit de faire
on va pas donner de temps m'a prédit tu
fais 55 en tout qui ont envie d'y aller
retour aller retour aller bon là les
blancs sont très bien il a réussi à
défoncer le rock avec h4 d'un f4
c'est juste deux pions plus et ses
positions massacrante et une minute
d'avant ce voyage donne le score et puis
on vient d'en avoir les fin de partie on
ouvrira les parties on viendra voir les
ait en fait on va faire un truc bien
vous allez voir en fait ça va même être
mieux en vrai et tu es excité à l'idée
de commenter kasparov
il ya des gens qui mecs qui plus que
kasparov mais après après où je l'étais
dans ses premiers retours moins qu'avant
en fait moins qu'avant
moins qu'avant où la dame enfermé a
notamment fermé ou sida m'enfermer j'ai
pas ça pue et j'ai vu un temps d'arrêt
je sais pas j'ai une hallucination suis
dit qu'est ce qui se passe mais c'est
devenu très chaud là et il s'est passé
quoi et des tours qui sont venus sur la
6e et à la dame qui ce mec qui se met en
danger
ça prend et on va prendre en g3 et on va
faire on apprend h6 il va mettre laurent
g7 et on va faire on va mettre la dame
en 17 et la tour en russie ce et on va
tout et l'échangé mètres la tour angers
6 ouais c'est marrant il a réussi à
défendre il a réussi à défendre ça c'est
un croire il trouve vraiment des super
ressources
il trouve d'excellentes ressources je
pensais qu'ils allaient faire d'un match
cet échec peut un peu plus et le feu
hier il est tellement mal autant damas 7
rolala ya tellement pas de temps les
gars et j'ai l'impression qu'il ya du
lag un peu c'est la folie là il les
trouve pas d'échec il n'ya pas des chats
qui tombent assez terrible ses terres il
avait plus d'échecs
comment ça s'est passé ce truc là et a
commencé à attaquer tout et tout d'un
coup il a plu des chèques
c'est incroyable ça c'est impressionnant
il avait retourné le truc qui s'est
retrouvé mal autant et tout d'un coup il
a il a plus rien eu
tracé ouais j'ai l'impression qu'il a il
a il a été un peu gourmand un moment
donné il avait sûrement un d'am-dam
échecs dames échec pour pour prendre une
nulle ça c'était oryx
ouais
il a
il ay là il a eu ce perpète qu'il a
ratée face à perpète si facile permet
tout cas mais ouais il a clairement
commencé à jouer pour gagner
terrible balle à la tête il se rappelle
pas de la prépa où il avait la prépa
jusque là fait il était tellement mal il
est remonté il s'est senti pousser des
ailes ça arrive ça
difficile difficile mais parfois en fait
tu perds un peu tu perds un peu pied tu
perds un peu pied tu sens que tu as
position s'améliore fortement et tu
perds le tage madame des huit pas mal
joué ils attaquent b2i l'ata que 5ème et
c'est hyper compliqué là à temps il ya
un pion de plus cependant pour les
blancs et d'un v8 c'est bien joué par
nial sarine qui doit connaître le thème
parce qu'il a joué qu'un assez
rapidement je vois qu'ils se rendent
coup pour coup
les joueurs qui se rendent coup pour
coup et ça lui où il y 10
ouais c'est pas évident comme décision
parce que tu fais qui a aidé de l'idc
curdin prend b2 du coup tu as tour ben
il va prendre 25 peut-être fait dames 3
mais tu dois rentrer dans cette finale
mais c'est un peu dégueu avec les blancs
d'avoir sa sortie de théories tu es un
peu moins bien
mais même en avantage c'est que tu te
prends pas le dame prend b2 relou parce
que ta tour ben ok ça c'est à l'air
suicidaire pour les noirs y'a pas encore
tour bessette et adam 1 mais s'ajuste f3
est tombé ça devant ça c'est injouable
c'est sûr que ça va pas ça donc ça
rentre dans cette finale dont je viens
de vous parler
par ne faut pas être fait sur la salle
batelière où il dit sera pas grave
écoute c'est pas grave du tout ouais
mais alors ce pion aux 3 est pas si
grave
il peut pas vraiment être attaqué ça
doit être égal qu'elle et ses 8 qui est
des si simple en apparence et 6 pour la
case de 5 à 3,07 tourache ses huit
cavaliers b3 carlier c1
ces cinq écart a lieu cinq pour jouer 17
ouais ça avantage noir ça quand même
ces avantages noir talent et casse pour
tes pièces mais après il ya quand même
la casse c'est simple pour le cavalier
b3 il va pas tout de suite ce que pas se
prendre des caisses et 7,17 quoi
tours hc 8 il va s'en prendre aux pions
c3
et la question en fait ce qui veut dire
c'est que si tu fais ça tu vas pas
vraiment être mieux puisque je la casse
c5 et mon cavalier la des cases
pour cette affaire tour ses huit tours
france et 3 c'est son idée tu peux faire
un petit bout de x 6 peut-être même ce
temps ici pour contrôler les cases du
doublage
pourquoi pas
un match vraiment agréable pour le
moment c'est un match sympa je referai
un retour à la fin de la saison en
option si on avait 90 minutes de 3 + 1
et 15,8 de bullet à la fin ce sera à mon
avis juste parfait c'est agréable juste
wall e 5 + 1 et peut-être de trop un
sinon c'est un match agréable ce match
est vraiment sympa il est serré n'est
fait à 80 cc j'aime bien j'aime bien
j'aime bien un 4 1 4 veut peut-être à
cinq à six tours à 5 et surtour c1 il
fait tour à 3 bêtement c'est le plan il
défend latéralement il veut envoyer son
pion peut-être ya des cahiers b5 et
prend à 7 un jour je trouve que c'est
pas mal
c'est bien les parties sont agréables
parce qu'elles sont serrés ya pas
vraiment un joueur plus fort que l'autre
au méthanier déconnecté olalalala les
amis à ça peut se voir la connexion de
nouveau c'est terrible c'est terrible
alors ça on m'a fait j'ai pu lire des
trucs
il se trouve que il se trouve qu'il
arrive sur avec zoom ouvert pour avoir
les caméras le partage d'écran et des
sites internet ça peut ça peut faire des
co d'internet de temps en temps pendant
quelques secondes et le temps que zoom
se remettent je fais pas ça qui est des
conflits de chez pas quoi de dns 10 p
enfin je peux pas exactement vous dire
mais mais il se trouve qu'à voir zoom
ouvert sur son ordinateur et d'autres
programmes peut créer des conflits avec
windows je sais pas quoi enfin voilà
c'est pas du tout mon mon domaine d
expertise mais c'est ce que j'ai pu lire
% à qui l'on dit parfois des gens qui
sont déconnectés de chasse points comme
pendant les tournois avec la connexion
zoom mais c'est le zoom qui peut faire
bugger les connexions voilà c'est des
trucs que j'ai pu lire après comment ça
marche pourquoi comment etc
ne me demandez pas je n'en sais rien
j'ai passé à des gens qui sont plus
doués que moi en informatique qui
peuvent comprendre le conflit d'adressés
ip de chez pas quoi qu'elle confie ça
peut générer mais c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
et donc du coup c'est ce qu'on a pu me
dire que c'est par rapport aux bugs avec
l'équipe d'arménie l'équivalent or
l'équipe d'anne c'est encore différent
mais amélie c'est pour ça que quand un
zoom est ouvert c'est encore plus
difficile de savoir quelle est la raison
de la déconnexion parce que parce que
très souvent c'est sa cause de zoom
alors après pour moi la grosse question
c'est du coup pourquoi on utilise ce
programme pour jouer des compétitions ou
là et là j'aime bien les plans tout d'un
coup parce que j'ai envie à b 5e 5
regardez sympa cavaliers ccist ont pensé
6 c'est ça l'idée
aulas il ya plus de temps dans cette
dernière partie roy a eu un high le roi
autour des deux là encore belle idée il
joue la colonne des avec toi un tour d
un zoom est assez bof du coup j'arrive
pas à comprendre pour les utilise
il s'entête et c'est tout le monde hein
qu'utilise zoom notamment la fille
chaise comme je crois que les tournois
sur 124 aussi sur zoom et c'est vrai que
si le programme lui-même créé des des
conflits qui font déconnecter les
joueurs de temps en temps et on voit
quand même beaucoup de déconnexion plus
que normalement je suis étonné qu'il ait
pas une seule une solution de repli qui
a été trouvé après ça doit pas être si
simple
d'ailleurs les mêmes problèmes sur les
autres programmes j'imagine mais
apparemment ouais c'est pas optimale
jamais il n'a pas il n'a pas trouvé pour
moi maintenant les blancs une position à
sympa mais j'avais pas vu l'idée noir
qui est te dire que le deux contre trois
blocs il veut jouer à leucate compte 3
s'est très bien joué de la part de
sarine j'ai complètement raté l'idée
donc l'idée c'est de te dire tu as trois
pions contre 2 qui n'avance pas et moi
j'ai quatre contre trois qui avance et
la tête ont pu reprendre la colonne
d'air après y'a plus de temps c'est
marrant c'est parti moment même en cinq
puissances se joue finalement à la
pendule le flou peur-là tour peut
repartir en âge suite pour h4 à tout
moment torah chute par intéressant il
met la tour en d3 pour le vent alors ils
empêchent 3e 1 donc à ce qu'il est en
train de faire c'est un travail de sape
niall c'est essayer de pouvoir près move
il fait h4 dans ce tempo
il met le pion h3 alors ça c'est
toujours une question l'avantagent du
pian h3c que ça peut créer un pion
passer à tout moment
mais est-ce que ça va y aller f4 joue
m 6 2 pouces et 6 il attaque ici à yaya
toure 3 fou prend 1,4 ou 34 il prend
c'est 4 y revient en d2 il a réussi à
échanger il pousse le pion c'est tout
reprend ses six tours b 8 ses sept tours
ses 8 ans quelle folie cette finale les
amis il va prendre un échec et puis on
prend un f4 dans le piège au le marlou
mais quelle défense une nouvelle fois en
manque de temps il est impressionnant et
maintenant toujours peut-être tour g5
même alors peut-être qu'il a un peu
grisé par la dernière fois qu'il a joué
le gain et tour h6 il va faire cavalier
prend non ils gardent il prend pas le
pion il joue le gain il continue à jouer
le gain il est incroyable ce pingouin
faut quand même qu'il fasse gaffe il
faut quand même qu'il fasse gaffe ça
échange de partout et au retour proche
d'eux a trouvé 4 ko le marlou au le
marlou quel mal ou ceux sarine
alors maintenant attendez c'est hyper
dur à gagner ça c'est hyper intéressant
cette finale n'est pas du tout simple à
gagner parce que le pur f5 protège
penguin qui propose nul ils meurent
avant elle et blanc oui bien sûr il va
il fait le zouk sangles mais en fait tu
dois mettre son adversaire en 12 janvier
progresser les salahi hyper dur à gagner
dans tous les cas tour bekkat était
super bien joué il fait le zouk gang à
l'été arrive cette partie va essayer de
pousser son pion à éponger 6 le retour
il va pas la gagner sarine sa magnus on
avait gagné une belle vie ici n'est pas
6 x a en tout cas ça tourne ça va être
facile pour m bellechasse a gagné ça il
ya une méthode pour mettre les blancs
zukang
faut-il encore la connaître et sa
palette de
le cas l'effet retour aussi c'est un
endroit des quatre mais marrant cette
fin de partie
marrant ça tu as raté à tous réussissent
maintenant il va pouvoir approcher le
roi ouais ça y est trois ou quatre ça
semblait fait c'est pas encore fini fini
mais ça va l'être
ça y est le roi qui doit s'écarter et il
va falloir maintenant réussir à il
s'empare du pion enfin est maintenant à
faire les chèques ça il a il a enfin
réussi après tous ces efforts a récupéré
le pion et maintenant c'est roy tour
contre roi dame alors ça normalement
avec aussi peu de temps sur la pendule
c'est un jeu d'enfant mais encore tenté
des pâtes il va encore y avoir des
pièges vraiment sympa la cette fin de
partie pour la peine est là c'est bien
joué
maintenant il a mis la position il a le
look gang et là il va y avoir les bons
petits échecs qui font du bien dames 5
ce n'est peut-être pas le coup escompté
mais là il faudrait qu'il refasse le
zoom non il s'est hissé planté il
voulait faire il a mis ce clic ça il a
réussi à le faire aller terrible cette
fin de partie incroyable c'est marrant
aller il va enfin mettre le système
d'âmes 1,3 bouche dame bien aidé à me
prend h7
et ça va faire le point pour ni al
sarine que d'efforts que d'efforts et
une nouvelle fois andrew teng qui qui
est moins bien qui se sort des griffes
de son adversaire et qui essaye de lui
planter en contre et qui se fait et qui
de ce fait contre compterait aide
fois deux fois consécutive il a un peu
fait la faute les gars il ya eu 137 quoi
dans cette dernière partie une partie
qui a duré une partie qui était vraiment
sympathique et ça s'est joué alors fait
voir un peu la combinaison qui a décidé
du truc c'est roy prend 1,4 tour b 4
quel marlou impressionnant en fait c'est
ici que me poser la question pourquoi il
a pas fait cavalier prend 1,4 à ce
moment-là vous prendre qu'à trois points
4 alors ok c'est probablement nulle mais
sa part et c'est quand même beaucoup
plus simples y avait très peu de temps
ouais
c'est marrant qu'ils soient pas rentrer
là dans l'évolution garder le cavalier
il a dû se trouver très malin il a dû se
trouver très mal on va revenir un peu
sur l'arrêt sur image il a dû se trouver
très malin et du coup en fait il a voulu
aller arrêter le pion est alors après
pour arrêter de compte une galère ce qui
contrôle la case là donc il est venu
comme ça ouais il aurait dû commencer
par tour à sept du coup échec 3 et m6
qui prend le cas de prise 4 6 4 et
aurait pas eu le bon il y aurait autour
des 4 coins f3 je sais par une connerie
mais à et ça c'est nul nul mais le tour
b 4 c'était quand même assez assez
piégeur
non je pense que c'était et c'est
toujours resté à plus ou moins normale
pour les dauphins plus ou moins normal
c'est resté toujours défendables pour
les noirs même si là après ces 5 il a
juste raté puis on prend g3 qui ont
pranger 3h de roy f2 et maintenant fou
b5 avec l'idée fou c'est ici ça a changé
d'âme
bon après il y avait tellement plus de
temps c'est facile radia après après
coup on cavaliers f 1 pouces et 6 qui
est 3h de tours d2 roigé un tour j'ai
deux mais c'est facile à dire avec le
recul mais sarine qui voit là c'est
juste pour illustrer une variante mais
qui a et qui a eu plusieurs gains un peu
de ce type là qui s'est retrouvé mal et
qui a recontré mais franchement k3
sarine à la sortie du 5 + 1 vu les
défenses que ça andrew teng je sais pas
lequel des deux est favori les a mis en
garde washington qui clairement fait un
truc il a raison de le faire
il entre à checker un peu les ouvertures
il va vouloir checker des trucs précis
tout cas c'est il a il a perdu ses deux
parties par manque de lucidité
en réalité il a man il a manqué de
lucidité
malheureusement ouais c'est là là c'est
la pause je vais vous dire quand ça
reprend je crois qu'il ya je crois qu'il
ya six minutes de pause donc c'est censé
amener ça repartira 50 matches plaisants
après un match plaisant ce soir là on
est tombé sur un bon match au final on a
eu on a on a un peu de chance
certains le temps d'écran du contrôle
parental aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe compliqué
il ya le showdown qui est en train
d'être lancé sur la chaîne i di caro et
de gotham tichet ce genre train de voir
un peu ce qui se trame à part le czech
comme rue ils ont carrément décidé de ne
pas commenter les bonnes choses comme
ils ont vraiment rien à [ __ ] un
terrible terrible c'est vrai que c'est
un peu long mais quand même ils s'en
foutent totalement quoi c'est terrible
c'est terrible les est de trouver au
passage en fait les temps d'arrêt
j'ai pas le tangue les blagues marrer
c'est terrible en fait parce que moi
j'ai quand même discuté avec les gars de
chez sky j'arrive on fait quoi
il ya quand même le 965 m mvl machin
c'est un beau plateau nanani nanana et
wemmel speech s junior aussi jean louis
moncet juniors c'est d'aller vite mais
j'ai dit bon quand même maxime dit oui
machin et tout donc du coup mais ils
sont 41 carrément aller en mode oui bof
il ya le 960 extraordinaires sont au
dessus de tout quoi
extraordinaire
ou pas d'ailleurs
ouais le truc c'est que maxime babin le
truc c'est que on va dire que s'ils
avaient pas maxime non le tournoi genre
la semaine prochaine y aura la même
chose mais ce sera des rapides
il y aura magnus hikaru et compagnie
mais il y aura pas maxime donc dans ce
cas là bon les matchs sont sympa aussi
mais là quand il ya maxime serait quand
tu es français
fa c'est dur de regarder rendre houten
ya le sarine cantat mvl potentiellement
contre kasparov crème ou contre carl
c'est nous contre hikaru juste c'est ça
tombe très mal
c'est comme si à un moment donné tu à
roland garros juniors et puis et puis
sur le central ta monfils contre nadal
étudie les gars on va aller regarder le
court numéro 18
il y a
il ya un joueur américain montre un
joueur indien bombes qui sont même pas
super fort en vrai tu vois ça un peu
c'est un peu compliqué on va dire d'elle
magnus en même temps c'est vrai c'est un
peu compliqué même c'est du 960 même
même voilà même m6 et d'exhibition et
c'est là la question n'est pas là mais
bon ça fait un peu bizarre pour le
public français quoi pour nous tu as
même moi j'ai envie de voir pas
honnêtement j'ai envie de voir maxime
c'est normal c'est un copain et tout on
le voit tout le temps dans le chat on a
on a envie de voir la partie de maxime
tous donc c'est vrai que c'est un peu
spécial mais après voilà on a réussi à
trouver une manière de faire les deux on
va dire ça comme ça
pas super fort ça a quand même c'est pas
les spéciales seront bien non plus ouais
enfin après là si tu tapes le match et
même pas si un des deux qui est dans le
top 100 mondial
est-ce que sarine il est donc top 100
mondial je peux checker sa sas à ce
check assez facilement je sais checker
puisque tant que c'est sûr qu'il y ait
pas d sign je suis loin d'être sûr que
ce soit top 100 mondial 1 niall sarine
il et 167e mondiale
tu vois ça fait même pas le cut à roland
garros un même sur les grands chelems ça
fait pas le cut donc et tang temps qui
doit être vie sociale
j'arrive la lumière des gages arrivés
donc en réalité deux joueurs qui sont
quand même loin du top 100 mondial
à côté tu vas avoir le numéro 4 mondial
qui est français contre potentiellement
le champion du monde ou une légende soit
c'est comme ça et mon fils sampras ou
quoi alors bon voila mais mais oui on
peut pas dire que c'est du top niveau
mondial
sans vouloir manquer de respect aux deux
joueurs c'est sais pas c'est pas le
propos ici mais voilà il faut il faut
aussi être réaliste 1 je trouve pas ce
que c'était pour les compètes mixera des
compétitions là sont mixtes 1 c'est ce
qu'on est en train de regarder est une
compétition mixte donc we wish pour les
compétitions mixtes se sont se sont ce
sont des compétitions mixtes tant que le
bar tanguy mais attends guillemets très
très cher si je joue beaucoup plus
fortement attendue je déteste jouer
contre temps
et mme béland speech est concernée par
mois serait loin d'être une partie de
plaisir
alors il le remettrait un tarot mais
alors monumental je rappelle quand même
que
en jouant avec un demi a ouvert ils
avaient battu oui il y avait commencé un
match catastrophique en étant menés de
cinq points et quand il s'était réveillé
il l'avait écrasée et willy est beaucoup
plus fort que ces deux joueurs c'est
pour dire que maxime contre des joueurs
pareils c'est qu'il suffit qu'il suffit
qu'il ouvre un oeil et sega même pas de
match en fait maxime et est vraiment
beaucoup plus fort que ces deux hommes
oui toutes les compétitions aux échecs
sont mixtes sauf les tournois féminins
me dorman exactement exactement c'est
tout à fait le cas sont à chaque fois
des compétitions mixtes
après c'est le critère qui choisit c'est
pas que ce soit des aml actualiser juste
le critère lots on prend les meilleurs
que ce soit des garçons ou des filles
donc c'est voilà c'est une contre-vérité
de dire que ce sont des compétitions est
ouverte uniquement aux hommes c'est pas
du tout le cas l'échec
trois des candidats est le cycle pour le
championnat du monde est ouvert aux
femmes
j'essaie de chercher ça en fait là en ce
moment sur mon téléphone j'avais oublié
j'avais pris dans ma main je ne savaient
plus pour quoi
c'était justement pour regarder les
appariements si j'ai réussi à les
trouver facilement
j'arrive toujours pas à les trouver je
vais essayer de régler sur twitter après
que la partie commence à 20h03
exactement je vais essayer de chercher
sur twitter ce que j'ai recruté leurs
trucs donc j'ai leur compte twitter et
ce qu'ils ont mis à à temps il ya le
stress je vous dis rolala il ya déjà des
parties de ouf firoud déjà kasparov
sympa figueres vidler wesley so nakamura
dominguez ok il ya une belle carlsen non
mais bon on peut pas on peut lvl carlo
scène tout le monde va comprendre qu'on
va aller jeter un oeil
ça commence tout de suite fort avec mpl
karl cents puis de nouveau flou pas fait
un peu oui on va faire on va faire une
petite pause du speech s
quand ça commence un camp d'été que dès
que j'ai les parties possible on va un
peu jeté un oeil un peu fou ça me refait
le même truc pierre faut que je refais
aux cuisses attendait et que je revienne
et normalement ça re focus sur moi c'est
s'en sert focus sur moi j'espère que sar
focus sur moi
donc c'est resté flou incroyable faire
le focus parfois au quai de la loire
bien re focus c'est sûr ok donc c'est
les pions pendant pendant qu'on règle et
ce truc flou bon c'est une position
qu'on aurait pu avoir un peu de tout à
l'heure à un peu plus tôt dans le match
donc pions pendant ses pions qui sont
une force parce qu'ils contrôlent des
cases au centre et qui sont avancés mais
qui sont des faiblesses parce qu'ils
sont sur des colonnes ouverte qui a
validé deux qu'il veuille changer les
pièces avec les blancs pour mettre plus
les pions sous pression les blés noirs
tuque sf6 elle un coût qui peut être
thématiques parfois il faut que ça
marche c'est qu'à et c4 pour jouer le
long de la colonne des s'en prendre aux
fous d'ailleurs c'est jouer j'imagine
que le fou va reculer en b 8 s'il ya un
problème immédiat ou ans et 7
mais le truc c'est que l'option est
doublement cloud est en fait ce qu'il
écrit comme ça aussi
donc les blancs peuvent continuer
peut-être par cavalli f4 et venir mettre
une énorme pression
la partie de maxime va commencer très
bientôt hélas là c'est par ben là c'est
vraiment parfait exemple de la pression
mise à fond par par les blancs qui vont
s'en prendre avec toutes leurs pièces
option dessin qui hélas ont une partie
qui illustre très bien et la difficulté
pour pingon alors les lots en bullet on
va jeter un petit oeil
irene qui affiche rim 3350 ça fait un
peu peur ar mais si dominant bullet ça
va être ça en fait ça a été un massacre
fait un gars tellement a une réputation
d'excellent joueurs de bullet alors on
peut faire cavalier ou 3 parce que sur
des quatre y apprend des quatre on joue
le clouage bas il le fait
là là là c'est vraiment le parfait
exemple j'espère comme arrache ses 150
ans en bullet récemment ah oui peut-être
cette nuit mais bon il affiche quand
même 200 points de plus que l'autre
la tour d2 enfin tu rajoute juste de la
pression et ça va craquer ouais des
katas fou prend bessette est sarine qui
va faire un premier enfin un premier
écart en fait une voire deux points
d'avance
et le truc c'est que il partit avec deux
points de retard en fait il a
complètement raté son début de match et
sexy gagner qui prend deux points
d'avance il va faire très mal là il peut
déjà encaissé le pion 1
mais c'est vrai que s'il commence à
construire sa victoire
cependant je vois pas les parties de le
carl scène mvele qui s'affiche dès que
ça arrive vous tient au courant
et là on avise sarine fut une erreur
stratégique dans le match qui l'a déjà
fait à plusieurs reprises et que je fais
très fréquemment c'est qu'il a quelque
chose devient déjà cuits donne une
position avec un pion plus bon c'était
tout prendre tout ce que je vais montrer
ce dont je vous parlais et le truc c'est
qu'il trouve le seul moyen de se mettre
en danger et parce que c'est pas si
gagnant que ça mais avec une minute
vingt ils auraient pu voir une minute 15
dans cette position c'est quand même
très tranquille et a vraiment
l'impression de jouer pour de résultats
et d'avoir le temps d'asseoir ta
technique avec 32 secondes
l'exemple et 45 secondes perdues peuvent
mettre en danger
après je peux comprendre à ce truc là
sont durs à gagner quand même je regarde
en même temps en parallèle sur mon
téléphone par rapport aux à la partie
mbl carlson qui devrait partir alors je
crois qu'ils ont du retard ils ont un
peu de retard à l'allumage
ça va pas nous faire de mal ainsi un peu
de retard ça paraîtra à suivre ce match
là au pire jusqu'à la fin très
tranquillement j'ai déjà serrée à deux
heures de jeu ouais c'est vrai que cette
première heure et demie et est longue et
dure deux heures mais ça ça doit être
nul puisque à tours vient en d2 mais
elle va venir en 1/4 je pense
allez bien passé puisque elle protège l
attaque
et magnus ça va ça va être ici et on va
regarder on va regarder les parties de
magnus contre mvl aussi simplement
n'attend que ça débute apparemment est
un peu de retard on va faire les deux en
même temps il va me va bien échangé
bonne défense une nouvelle fois un
grosse défense du pingouin qui défend
très bien en fait retour à troyes ici je
pense ce que sa force 3 e 2 h m ah oui
mais ça va et puis en fait il faut pas
vrai très bien joué tour à trois tours
f3 encore ouais ça c'est très solide en
la maison pingouin est très solide en
défense
pas d'erreur f5 f4 maintenant alors il
faut que le roi blanc en fait fort avec
le roi blanc retourne dans la majorité
en bloquant le roi à 3 j'aime pas parce
qu'il a la tour du quoi je pense je
pensais qu'ils essayent de couper le roi
repartir comme ça pour pousser son pion
alors ils essayent de tournicoter il va
faire tomber deux maintenant mais non de
façon roi ces cinq ans avec l'option à
deux ils auraient eu le plan de repartir
avec le roi mais bon ce ne devait pas
marché du tout hein mais aurait pu avoir
les spots voir retourner avec le roi de
l'autre côté pour aider la majorité
non je pense qu'on devrait avoir les
partis qui vont s'afficher en tout cas
j'espère
que les partis 1960 vont s'afficher en
tout cas moi je vois déjà la position
sur follow chess mais ça devrait face ça
doit être aussi sur chaise bon ben ça
devrait arriver sur chaise comme aussi
en 63 kg a pas encore commencé un mais
qui devrait commencer sa fiche à ils
sont environ 2 et 3 on les suivra au
maximum
je regarde en fait c'est un truc
officielle donc là c'est à petit c'est
une petite nîmes jour 1 de nouveau à
visuellement c'est mieux pour les blancs
je vous rassure mais mais c'est pas
censé être grand chose
les normes vont réussir à s'activer ils
vont mettre les tours sur colonna a
essayé ils vont proposer l'échangé dame
prend la case de 4 avec un cavalier les
blancs ont pas le temps de finir leur
développement et à prendre le dessus
j'essaye de trouver un live officiel de
lots de lait de l'événement là bas
ce qui serait un peu l'embellie
ce qui serait l'embellie pour avoir une
idée de ce qui se passe avec des caméras
machin mais je trouve pas pour le moment
à voir si j'ai réussi à faire cette
embellie ces saint louis jazz club qui
doit stream
je n'arrive pas à les trouver oui cette
finale qui avait prend ces trois était
une option mais normalement tu as réussi
à échanger un fou machin est sûre ce
petit problème avec le fou c8 qui va se
retrouver en danger avec flex 3 qui
arrive
ce qui me rassure c'est que ça a
commencé sur aucun live
ça me rassure parler un salut ludwig
c'est parti alors j'ai toujours pas les
parties la dent elles vont elles vont
arriver mais c'est vrai que ces partis
mais ça va ça va arriver
les u14 de maxime je vais voir ce que
fait hikaru en fait les gars j'ai
regardé en même temps j'arrive c'est
parti ça va se jouer sur le fou ces huit
mal développées et le pingouin qui doit
réfléchir peut-être à faire çà çà çà çà
çà c'est les options sur qu'il prend à
deux petits coups de fouets f3 et jouer
contre se fout mal développés mais tu
peux dire que tu vas avoir un pion - et
que c'est dangereux
ce serait très compréhensible aussi
attendait donc voilà l'enjeu un peu de
la position et c'est ce qu'il a joué je
ne nous avait pas menti quand je l'aï
dit à temps il faut que je regarde ce
que voilà je vais me caler sur le truc
d'hikaru qui est recalé sur le truc
d'hikaru va me permettre de voir à quel
moment as
à quel moment réussi à voir l'échiquier
vlk soir vient juste après je sais pas
j'ai pas les apparemment les
appariements pardon lui dit tu peux de
chacun j'attends que chess com met les
l'epg est né sait ce que c'est ce
qu'attendent hochet la chaîne d'hikaru
donc tant qu'on les a pas on peut pas
regarder donc pouvait mettre autant de
fois que vous voulez dans le chat ça a
commencé
si j'ai pas la partie pour la mettre sur
l'écran ça peut avoir commencé j'y peux
rien m-real caruana après et après la
ronde 3 par contre dès que ça va avoir
commencé j'aurais j'aurai avec le truc
de 10 carouge et le contrôle
donc et détroit mve elle n'a qu'à ouais
c'est sympa lvl maca oui déjà il ya deux
chaises bon mais moi j'attends que ce
soit là pour pouvoir mettre l'échiquier
facilement offert aux cadres donc et il
joue toujours le fou un mal développés
mais je dois dire que là c'est hyper
frustrant de ne pas avoir les partis où
ils ont joué que 4 ou non mais en 960 tu
rates pas grand chose quand tu rentres
tu rates le début en vrai parce que
c'est tellement compliqué que le
l'ouverture et acea est assez complexe
il n'y a pas 150 milles au vainqueur à
qui mixe à 150000 euros de prix mais ce
qui est déjà pas mal pour un 3 sur
internet sur trois jours près toujours
la même difficulté 1 quand il ya autant
d'argent et pas de sécurité
ça fait toujours un peu peur mais bon
bah on va dire que ces joueurs du top
niveau et que ça va être faire en tout
cas on l'espère ou alors il sut
complètement gotham chest qui a pas les
partis qui arrive ça sue du lourd
alors on va pouvoir je vais faire le
truc backup ainsi jamais j'ai une idée
de ba cap voilà ces avantages blanc
parce que le cavalier va dominer le fou
louera peut essayer de venir en des cats
essence est nul ce rapport au matériel
mais c'est très chiant à défendre je
pense que c'est censé être nul mais
c'est chiant en blitz en tout cas je
vais aller me chercher le l'échiquier à
l'échiquier backup qui est là pour qu'on
ait un peu la partie et la position donc
max à l'eiblen pouvoir vous allez
laisser ce cette fameuse lettre se dé se
dérouler mais comme je vous dis c'est
chiant il ya le cavaly cavaliers
contrefout rapport en matériel avec les
fourchettes pions isolé
wade est que le junior est fini je
switche arbitre immédiatement mais c'est
quand même beaucoup la rue c'est juste
des cités de ce noble even quoi enrich
persiste à penser que le format de
l'even tu es très problématique beaucoup
trop long et que ces problématiques mais
quand même rien dit à une fille ruth la
kasparov aussi
il commence à se faire enfermer la tour
le pingouin haïti ici c'est faire
tourner ton g2 ça rentre enfin retourner
c'est pas clair mais c'est devenu
complètement hors de contrôle cette
histoire il va prendre à 6 il va prendre
g2 il va prendre trois à est maintenant
il ya le pion des qui fit le fou qui
vient aussi c'est le pion des qui file
ouais voilà le pingouin à mon avis cette
défaite elle va faire mal mais ça là
elle fait très mal et d1 dames c'est
game voir ça rime très heureux salah
elle fait mal ça fait 5 2 en termes de
victoires et on va aller chez 5,3 en
termes de victoire ça fait mal dans le
sport cces 4 à moins de 10 mètres que
les victoires histoire de de faire de
faire le tour on va mettre la position 2
maxime je peux la mettre
je vais voir comment je fais je vais
faire un truc un peu un peu hybride pour
le moment donc on est côté mvl
on va être cottage faire le truc hybride
pour commencer
tant que je trouve pas les partis de
l'autre côté on va faire ça comme ça et
on va se demander ce qui se passe dans
cette position que j'ai pas pu voir
avant alors vas cela repassé depuis le
début je peux pas bouger des pièces par
nom par contre tu as le board révèle
surtout à ce point comme alors à temps
si tu peux m'envoyer le lien si tu peux
m'envoyer le lien de l'échiquier du coup
ce serait parfait parce que moi je n'ai
pas dans la liste mais il se peut mais
c'est surtout à ce point comme events il
me le faut dans 13 points comme live
celui là je l'est aussi mais assez
l'échiquier sur lesquels que j'ai
maintenant sur lequel je peux pas bouger
les pièces en fait c'est ça c'est ça mon
problème en fait c'est pas ne pas avoir
l'échiquier c'est de ne pas pouvoir
bouger les pièces le problème en soi
sinon l'échiquier est là donc on va se
passer cette partie parce que ça avec
jusqu'à maintenant on n'a pas eu le
temps de la voir alors eu 4 c 5
donc c'est pas une si jeune on voit les
cavaliers les toutes les pièces mal mise
qui est b3 c5 je pensais pour empêcher
la prise du centre des quatre pour
éviter que deuxième sur vienne au centre
effet kébé 3 il attaque le pion b6
d'accord prépare un flanqué taux d'amh
eux deux ils se développent g6 bon fiant
kétou logique rock logique x 6 des trois
quarts lycées 6 g 3 sacs et ses trois
fous ces 3 1 pouces et 3 auquel a voulu
échanger et g5
il veut jouer avec grand roque j'aime
bien les blancs j'adore les blancs ici
j'adore la position de maxime parce que
si le roi se barre ici donc s'il veut
faire gros qu'un supplément avec la
souris je laissais de vous montrer à la
souris c'est pas facile pas faire de
flèches peut rien faire messi fait grand
roque
on va voir le fou h1 qui va être un
génie sur la grande diagonale
il va être très dangereux et en plus on
va avoir des ruptures peut-être un jour
avec des 4,6 fait petit rock maintenant
c'est suicidaire il a pas de case noire
et g5 palmarès de g5 j'empêche f4 si on
prend qui on prend mais avec les
boulangers d'un mach 5 comme coup j'ai
peut-être eu 5 pour pousser au centre
j'ai peut-être juste tour eu un geste
attaf 4 quand même j'ai l'impression
d'avoir toutes les options côté blanc
ici j'aime beaucoup à la position de
maxime contre magnus ici pour le moment
en tout cas je trouve que la position
est très intéressante car c'est du 25 +
5 août 25 + 10 donc il ya le temps pour
les deux joueurs mais clairement soit
soit 2,5 pour se réveiller le fou soit
f4 je pense soit d'un match 5
il a joué f4 est c et ku dans le style
de maxime
le truc c'est que pions pranger 5-fu
price capture développe une pièce
t'attaques lecavalier ses 7 qui sera en
prise 1 le fousseret f4 il attaquera le
cavalier talent à tour en face de la
dame
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
un vous pouvez bouger les pièces berwin
heures alors attends comment tu fais ça
je peux pas bouger les pièces un sur ton
lien je ne sais pas comment tu fais en
vrai je ne peux pas bouger les pièces
sur à sur chaise comme event je peux
juste voir les coups mais je peux pas
bouger les pièces tête des gens qui ont
un secret un je peux rentrer les
variantes d'ordi donc ça c'est avoir
dormi mais je peux pas bouger les pièces
comme jeu on s'en fout complètement de
la vente d'or 10 a aucun intérêt
il fait cavalier a eu 6 ok il s'en prend
aux fous
est-ce qu'on peut être tenté un fouet
seront peu pâle à quel point f4 je vais
essayer de ramener le fou h1 sur la case
h5 pour mettre la pression sur f cette
île fait 5 alors 5 ses responsables
comme coup mais c'est hyper logique hein
sait on en parlait juste avant le x h un
jeu vous sur la grande diagonale
d'accord donc il est extrêmement fort et
on va partir du principe que les noirs
vont prendre le fouet 4 et donc que les
pions sur noir vont très bien joué avec
le fou de carte blanche
donc on va qu'on va avoir un jeu
stratégique supérieur on se libère aussi
la case de 4 pour la dame où le fou donc
dame j'essaie de jouer alors d'amener
cette menace cavaliers pro f 4 suivi de
dame prend 1,5
ce qu'on pouvait pas reprendre de gc
cloud et donc les blancs qui joue autour
d eux un avec l'idée de blinder le pion
aux 5 et je pense que magnus va jouer h5
ici non quoique par manu c'est un
problème sa tour c'est son roi 8 en fait
il peut toujours faire grand requin ici
dans parce que c'est 1960 donc à la
possibilité de faire grand roque
alors que la partie dans le match de
sarry n'est toujours pas terminée mais
mes sarine juste pour vous dire qu'il y
ait deux nouveaux gagnants et qui va
faire enfler le score est donc le le
match
le match est en train de tourner court
pour pour andrew teng
finalement il se passe ce qu'on avait
imaginé depuis le début il a mené 2-0 et
et il vient de se prendre un set 2 il se
fait il se fait vraiment largement
dominé en août m
je vais mettre le score à jour mais il
ya maintenant trois points d'écart entre
ces deux hommes
ce qui est assez énorme donc mvl ouais
donc revenons à nos moutons le problème
des noirs c'est le roi 8 d'accord parce
qu'avec ce roi 8 qui joues pas tu peux
pas faire jouer tes trois pions sans
trop d'accord 17,7 à vii tu peux pas y
toucher
ta tour des huit du coup elle
n'intervient pas dans le jeu parce que
si tu fais des six tu te fais prendre tu
te fais ouvrir le roi et a pas trop de
plans alors après avec les blancs c'est
pas non plus facile de percer mais je
pense qu'il veut du damage 5-fu 4
quelque chose comme ça écoutez je laisse
star in times qu'on est quand même sens
c'est un peu un peu suivre le match donc
on un peu les caméras ont un peu ce qui
se passe ça ferait écran noir suit non
mais le pingouin qui est qui et qui en
difficulté on suit avec les caméras elle
a fait tour à schwyz
alors l'idée tourache 8
elle est simple en fait ce sera plus
facile de switcher des échiquiers
d'ailleurs une fois qu'on aura les
médias pas départi sûr je sais pas si ça
va venir ronde de ou pas on survit dream
on pourra se faire un truc plus sympa en
fait on pourra se mettre les positions
il ya un cash-flow thouars les jeunes ya
vingt-cinq mille dollars ouais donc
turaci toi l'idée c'est de faire h5 et
de pas avoir d'armes proche 5,7 un
visage 5 mai avait dame prend 1,5
donc avec les blancs la question c'est
comment tout si tu réussis à jouer des
quatre avec les blancs tu as que même
dame e3 et des cats sacrifice de qualité
pour tout ouvrir au centre est bon je
pense pas mais tu as peut-être dame e3
tous rêvent de et d4 est une idée en
fait
dames et trois tours f2 on voit pas la
pendule mais non la lave avec avec cette
mise en place un jeu pas vouloir ajouter
les façons il reste 13 me de 15000 ça se
joue par la pendule 1 l'aca ne joue pas
du tout à la pendule
ça joue vraiment la position so blonde
jouée on voit le dernier coup tours h8
donc clairement
alors est-ce que ce cavalier b tron veux
pas leur place et jaurès qui a aidé 2 4
et moi j'aimerais bien essayer de placer
un qui a été six échecs ou quoi mais je
le vois pas alors d'un match 5 ça peut
être une idée marchandises mais je pense
qu adam g6 et du coup si tu échanges il
remet son pion h vers le centre il joue
d'un match 5 c'est son coup mais il va
falloir comprendre ce qu'il fait sur
dame g6
va probablement jouer d'un match 4 et
c'est maxime qui a les blancs on s'est
mis un côté maxime pour regarder la
partie d'accord d'alger 6,6 vue d'un
match 4 et après métral fois en quatre
pour chasser la dame
c'est extrêmement intéressant alors que
niall sarine juste pour vous mettre à
jour et de nouveaux gagnants contre le
pingouin donc ça va faire probablement
quatre points d'écart
donc là le score qui enfle quand le
match sera mathématiquement gagner on
pourra vraiment complètement switcher c4
alors ces 4 il a pris il a fait cas et
c'est un éprise prise remonte l'action
lors d'y donner un truc logique il des
idées c'est de faire cailler des quatre
pour essayer d'aider changer les
cavaliers face à un sacrifice de pions
très fort il y aurait pu avoir des us is
fuoh 5 à la fin pour ceux qui voient
jusqu'au bout sur qui a aidé quatre si
on prend tout en d4 on peut faire
réussissent le pire arrive 7 est cloué
et on réussira à mettre le foin e5 est à
faire une heure une enfilade quai saint
camille une erreur de maxime
c'est malheureux parce que qu'est et des
cadres devaient donner un gros avantage
il devait avoir quelque chose dans une
variante qui la recouvrait un pleutre
osef
c'est pas du tout rires je me suis je me
suis entretenu avec les gars de chasse
comme contrairement aux russes j'ai fait
j'ai fait la concession de quand même
faire l'événement de chasse comme qui
est quand même sympa mais même si je
trouve que c'est celle on est là c'est
vraiment dommage ça aurait duré deux
heures ça faisait 18 heures-20 heures
c'était très bien même en général mais
j'en ai discuté et contrairement aux
russes qui vraiment s'en bat l'oeil
total en fait on fait un peu les deux
après là en plus c'est mal tombé j'avais
dit ça dépend aussi de l'appariement ce
qu'on savait pas si ce que ça tomberait
si ça tombe la nouvelle dominguez tu
vois c'est une chose mais mvl magnus ça
reste quand même une partie qu'on a tous
envie de voir donc là c'est vraiment
vraiment tombé sur à sur la grosse
partie s'assure jaidi cnvl kasparov mvl
mbezele carlson om velika rousset c'est
quand même c'est quand même les trois
chocs qu'on a vraiment envie de regarder
donc d'un mach iii est ce que ça marche
pas une c'est sûr qu'il veut pas faire
d'amen 3 parce qu'en fait les trucs que
tu pour protéger les pions je fais
dernière trop dam dom était à chaque
fois pas très bien placé tirer plutôt h4
de base mais d'un match 4 est ce que
vous prendrez 3 et un coup
écoute antonymes je te recommande de
poster ton sévère de chasse comme du
coup pour leur expliquer comment comment
faire du marketing quoi en tout cas
position grave voit pas les temps ces
onze minutes chacun pour le moment van
der le retour aussi jouable way d'âme
des uns le retour est aussi jouable faut
quatre fromages cet emprunt sur fou 4
c'est qu'il ya dame prend h5
qu'est-ce que je mette la caméra plus
haut c'est hyper dur à régler cette
caméra elle est vraiment allé
honnêtement très difficile à régler il a
fait d'âme des uns
fé dann d'air alors que le score est le
score le score de l'autre côté encore
enflé 1
c'est maintenant 7 3 puis celle à la c
ça tourne à la démonstration en plus le
match est quasiment finie a peut-être
des dames à quatre plus tard et françois
jacq maintenant h5 et vous voyez le truc
c'est que du coup à le développement
bizarre de caral scène qui commence à
prendre un peu sens avec h4 qui va
arriver
charles que ça tourne pas forcément
super bien pour max qui a réussit pas à
mettre la marche avant avec des quatre
caravanes est revenu dans la partie way
hk tour f2 peut-être qu avait lieu
devant c'est la même idée il veut des 4
après on sait que maxime a des
difficultés à bien jouer sur internet 1
au contraire de magnus qui est devenu un
artiste en la manière dans la matière
mais on sait que maxime est un joueur
qui est qui c'est beaucoup moins fort
surtout dans les cadences plus longue
sur internet et c'est vrai c'est vrai
que ça peut ça peut ça peut poser poser
problème après ce que c'est les parties
sortent pas sur chaise comme live c'est
une catastrophe
c'est vraiment là c'est vraiment la cata
car aïeux de mécano biologique un lieu
qui prend f4 il veut il veut protéger g3
il veut préparer des 4 6/4 assène va
jouer grand roque ski exposition 9,68
dont les avantages non je pense pas
grand roque c'était le coup que je
pensais pour ramener une tourangelle
huit bons maxime qui a une position
compliquée position d' attaque c'est le
genre de position qu'il affectionne
contrairement à contrairement à magnus
qui aime peut-être moins ce type de
position et alors que dans que dans la
partie ii de niall sarine ça va faire
cinq points d'écart
voilà on s'est vraiment c'est vraiment
un massacre total
le but du rock noir est d'amener la tour
sur la colonnade ou sur la colonne j'ai
un coup d'oeil chez kasparov alors
attends c'est faisable position
complètement différente côté fil rouge à
quatre par aof
mais les blancs ont de nouveau une
position plus agréable et noir ont pas
réussi à re ok si rogers à l'eiblen 1
le gros rock et des quatre noms c'est
exactement l'idée qu'on avait
or die annonça comme une faute à cause
de hg fou pranger trois tours proche
d'eux on va regarder la ligne
ma question c'est qu'est ce qui se passe
sur roy prend h 2 à dammaj 6 dame prend
1,3 dur à voir ça maxime a raté ça c'est
dur à voir âgées fou pranger trois tours
proche de roi proche de damas six dames
prend 1,3 c'est dur c'est pas sûr que
mcnish le voit c'est assez dur à voir
parce que talent fou qui parle la
diagonale ta leroy qui part faut penser
que tu as encore d'art machiste dame e3
mais là j'ai tout rangé 3 jouable ah
ouais mais je pense que tu as moins
envie parce que la dame elle va venir en
h5 ou en h7 tons chauds f4 il va se
faire manger tu ouvres h5 même plus on
prend tout reprendre à mach 5 sa menace
et ont cavalé eu deux tons pions h2 et
halfway f4 en l'air un peu est à la tour
qui revient à angers 8 arrêts nancy
magnus il voit à alger où pranger trois
tours pour age 2 ça sent la défaite à da
pour maxime sur cavaliers prendre face
on ne peut pas prendre sur puis on prend
part ne peut pas prendre du cavalier
puisqu'ils à [ __ ] en f1 sur fion prend
prendre du pillon ce peut-être possible
et peut-être même des tours prend un
champ d'un mach 5 tours h 8
ça fait hyper peur et du coup prendre du
fou c'est ce qu'on voulait faire pour
essayer tous contre blindes tout blindés
mais il ya tout reprend h 2 donc ça peut
être mort très rapidement des maximes
une nouvelle fois sur internet c'est
marant il y arrive vraiment pas c'est
pas des erreurs qu'on doit faire
habituellement
alors que dans la partie et je vais je
vais vous montrer juste la partie de
tongs la fin de partie ce qui a une
grosse attaque de maths avec la tour
bien placé sur la septième rangée le fou
en b2 il fait dame f5 échec qui va
est-ce qui va prendre ici ou est ce
qu'il va faire 1 dames ci soit ces dames
prend h6 tout maintenir sous pression il
fait 1 5 ha et menace d'un match 7
matchs et il fait tomber le pingouin
donc le match la main en bois qui tourne
complètement à la démonstration est à
cinq points d'écart ça rime qui a 200
points de plus en bullet que son
adversaire
donc on pense je savais pas qu'il était
chez x n'était pas un mauvais joueur de
bullet mais je pensais qu'il se rendrait
de trois points dans les dents mais là
il est déjà +5
c'est complètement terminée pour pour
tag match clairement qui aura tenu ses
promesses pendant une heure et demie et
et tales qui aura baissé le rideau et
carl scène qui a pas vus il a fait
cavalier à cinq cavaliers à st gall je
vous
ah j'ai pris ce tour proche de damas si
c'est vraiment difficile
c'était vraiment difficile à voir mais
cooke avaler à 5 il a joué le truc plus
stratégique pour jouer du cavalier du
cavalier c4 mais maintenant maxime moi
j'aurais pensé à damas quatre lords il
propose pas du tout parce que ça fait
pas grand chose en vrai mais bon tu veux
qu'elle et ses quatre attaques et la
tour ça ça reste pénible 1
il n'a pas eu maxime a pas vus et
carlson n'a pas vu faut quatre selon
seysses mont fourcat très logique mais
c'est la suite après à moi j'avais pas
vu non plus s arrête à max je vous ai
dit et c'est j'ai le petit ordinateur
qui a qui a dit erreur donc je jette un
oeil pour savoir pourquoi c'est une
erreur après je vous ai dit voilà il y
avait il y avait cette variante l'acquis
jour il dit est très difficile d'avoir
j'aurais pas vu en parant rapide parce
que tout reproche de faut y penser et
voir que yade a réagi c'était vraiment
compliqué bon je trouve que les blancs
restent sous pression quand même
personnellement je peut-être que cesse
donner galles j'en sais rien mais bon
damage cinq tours des g8 germes sont que
c'est les noirs qui ont tous le jeu
devant le roi blanc damier 7 aussi
jouable damage 5 away marié peut-être
peut-être des propositions des changes
des dames qui le jeune est tous rêvent
de ces hyper logique ça permet de sortir
de la diagonale est maintenant le joueur
le joueur norvégien qui va peut-être
mettre sa tour en g8
ça semble être le coup logique mais
maxime qui a quand même une grosse
majorité de pièces
si vous regardez à l'est le roi parce
que manu silva une deux trois quatre
pièces contre contre 6 pièces en fait
les blancs ont toutes leurs pièces qui
joue sur sur les lois d'échiquier et sur
des karellis et quatre tours f3
peut-être un jour la dame par an à 4 est
bien mené une contre attaque éclair avec
le fougueux 4 s'est passé pas si clair
un légat sais pas
leur part est ce que tu as comme a enfin
mis la partie de l'autre côté je vais
essayer de regarder parce que ce sera
agréable de pouvoir bouger les pièces où
est ce que on est dans cette galère
incessantes
on est dans cette galère incessantes bon
aidants et dans l'autre match juste pour
faire un petite mise à jour
niall sarine et de nouveau devant dans
la partie qui pourrait il pourrait
encore faire gonfler le score 30 et g8
donc ça c'est le coup logique alors le
la difficulté pour pour magnus ça va ça
va être voilà de mener cette attaque de
maths parce qu'elle a une grosse
majorité de pièces blanches les blancs
sont en grand sur nombre allait droit
donc difficile après la difficulté de
maxime c'est que dès qu fait du dessin
que tu donnes des cases et qui a réalisé
cinq des machins où des cavaliers pros
f4 dame prend 1,5 c'est difficile de
pousser ce centre blanc et si tu pousses
pas le centre blanc c'est difficile
c'est difficile de faire quoi que ce
soit en fait les pièces sont quand même
bien recroqueville à la défense du roi
efi route ja kasparov et sephiroth jacky
à l'eiblen je préfère les blancs de visu
mais rien de sûr cinq minutes contre 7
c'est chaud et carl scène et n'accapare
dont 2000 casablanca calais nord il se
passe rien ok mais pas moins que se fait
déchirer pour moi j'avais prévu une
déchira là j'étais étonné du début de
match encore que là il a peut-être une
balle pour un peu revenir donc maxime
qui est revenu avec fougue et 2 et donc
vous voyez avec le fou en g2 il vient il
vient de couvrir son roi en fait un
bêtement mais ce qui est bien c'est que
t'as même pas des rois f1 parce que tu
vas te retrouver sur la diagonale du fou
si manu ce projet 3 je pense qu'on prend
du fou parce que ça permet de blinder le
pion h2 et le fou sera blindé par le
pion h 2 ça permet de faire une synergie
ou plutôt de maximois il n'a pas le
choix donc pour les pendules ces six
minutes contre 6 je jette un oeil pour
voir si les autres ont réussi à faire
mieux que mon système parce qu'ils ont
eu la même idée que moi ils m'ont l'air
d'être tout autant bloqué ils sont tous
autant bloquer coin c'est l'art est
totale avec le fou angers deux là qui
blindent bien on va voir comment magnus
attaque est ce qu'il va faire des dames
h7 est ce qui va on va voir on va voir
puisque faut quand même percer la
muraille un peut-être damage 7 avec
l'idée qu'ils avaient prévu quatre
prises f4 pris ce g3 et d'un match de
s'infiltre ahmed hammache cette maxime
de fouet aux quatre damage cinq fois f3
il veut suivre la dame en fait sur la
colonne h
si elle vient h7 on vit à eux quatre si
elle vient à saint conviant à f3 il veut
la suivre en fait le long de la
diagonale
ce qui peut ce qui peut fonctionner
est ce que le match de l'autre côté
qu'est ce qui se passe de l'autre côté
je jette un oeil
tang qui est revenu à 8 victoires à
quatre
donc bien joué ou g2
avec une position fou fou mais ça
d'accord position toujours aussi
compliqué donc faut veiller à être
l'idée c'est que si tu échanges les fous
de 4 blanc je suis pour à retoucher la
colonne h
donc à voir
je faut enlever cette question de maxime
qui doit vraiment se méfier des quidams
des trois mines
c'est le coup de l'ordi ce que
j'imaginais validé dan détroit serait
d'empêcher d'un match satisfait des 5
ouais j'aime bien le coup des cinq ici
je trouve que c'est beaucoup mieux de
dames détroit visuellement pas ce que tu
veux dire que le cavaliere à 5 est hors
jeu et qu'il a du mal à revenir puisque
la tour f 4 contrôler la case c4 et
maintenant les cribles ans eut réussi à
faire qui est des quatre cavaliers f5
qui est des quatre qui est bessin quatre
places et tu peux être très bien il ya
le pion f7 aussi qui peut être en l'air
moi j'aime bien les blancs mais après
après je vois les vals de l'ordi donc
qui me qui m'influence de l'autre côté
mais si tu me demandais quelle couleur
je joue ici je prends les blancs roye b
vite donc magnus qui part avec son roi
c'est avec ces bien joué ça
ça et c'est bien joué
c'est vraiment fait que le roi noir on
n'arrive pas à le mettre sous pression
et que sur dame f1 et la tourache cette
pièce blanche part plus active mais on
n'arrive pas sur quelle idée kathakali
c4 parce que lecavalier obstruait donc
maxime fait dam des trois accords il
veut sûrement cavaliers des quatre
cavaliers f5
donc il veut s'activer
rennes on ça va ça va ça va dam des
trois c'est bien joué alors dit propose
tour c'est 8 pour les noirs pour
maintenir le fait que sur qui a aidé ktk
et c4
ils empêchent les c4 et c4 est pas une
menace en france oaxaca la torah f4 qui
veille au grain
mais ça peut le devenir
ça peut le devenir j'ai juste un et de
mon côté à l'autre partie sarine qui a
un petit plus mais rien de rédhibitoire
pour le joueur américain qui a fait d'un
match 7
il reste 4050 pour maxime de 56 pour
karl seine doit pouvoir échanger les
dames et faire un par toi et frei pourra
pas mais il peut peut-être fait à ces
quatre peut-être un des six alors et
tout est changé
fear ou jack as part of ok ça va jouer
si lecavalier h3 peut sortir ou pas mais
sinon la position noir à l'air correct
les fouilles joue bien et le centre à
assez fort et n'a qu'à dominguez
[Musique]
attention tour deux tours aux cinq qui
peut faire mal à voir on reste sur mvl
contre carl scène joueur français qui a
le choix il peut prendre lâche cet homme
est fou et capturer damage deux camps
parce que d'un match 2 j'allais vous
dire menace pas vraiment c'est pour ça
que lui qu'on a le choix
donc ils échangent
he is it est un des six illustre calvet
temps il joue sur leach s
sur le truc dit car il a tout les game
comme normalement quand j'ai regardé
tout à l'heure il n'est pas les game
comme normal du tout peut-être elles
sont arrivés entre temps
non il n'a pas les game comme normal du
tout il a les mêmes échecs - sur
lesquelles il peut pas bouger
juste comme il est sur un design un peu
différent il a pu s'organiser à mieux
mais ils sont aussi autant bloqué avec
moi ceci est une fête news
sont bloqués comme nous sur surfaces
vont ils peuvent pas faire un truc
normal et les russes pareil un shampoing
de jeter un oeil
ils ont exactement le même problème
malheureusement
l'abbé sur d'autres sites ils ont
peut-être pas le problème c'est un
silver star tant mieux pour eux fêter
ses 1 sur mon stream ch pourrait aussi
changer de configuration mais là je suis
bloqué sur ce stream là sur mon stream
pourrait faire la config jeter un oeil
au score de l'autre match s'arrête qui
va remettre un point ça refait cinq
points d'écart
le match est un massacre je crois qu'ils
vont entrer en pause
le cavaly qui arrive en c4 c'est ce
qu'on voulait éviter la tour qui va
devoir partir en e2 escaré les ans et
cathy les pénibles
voilà l'autre match n'est pas encore
fini il reste encore une partie de 3 + 1
il reste il reste encore du temps mais
bon allez c'est pas clair encore mais
carillon c4 est vraiment pénible il
attaque le pion aux 5,6 et il va y avoir
quoi il va devoir faire d eux
magnus d'affaires f e et le pion au sein
il va être hyper faible maxime va devoir
essayer de faire un truc avec du
cavalier de d4 et navigue était le verbe
et cinq des six
maintenant le pingouin qui est vraiment
dans le dur les gars et dans les autres
partis farruggia kasparov
el khyari h3 qui s'est fait enfermer
kasparov dans le dur dominguez naka
attention dakar 1 les pions sont sur
noir allaient droit
c'est une finale qui peut être
dangereuse il peut se retrouver à perdre
à saint-jean retour prend des deux tours
prend des deux caves et prend des deux
est qui et qui reviendront c4 ça peut
être dangereux un pur pour le joueur
américain est la maxime il a joué des
six il a échangé roi prend alors la
maxime seilhac une question en fait est
ce que il maintient eu cinq en vie ou
pas si la réponse est oui ça va mais
magnus qui va faire a6b cinq tours
achoui tourage 5 pour preuve cinq ça
c'est son plan on voit on voit l'autre
côté ça rime qui se tient les mains bon
il se passe rien de spécial dans sa
partie
myfab et 5 direct à roye b ici ses
affaires b53 b6 peut-être et tourache 8
il faut protéger ces quatre mais c'est
dû au ray l'ardiden -3 aurait fait je
suis pas si sûr un tour j'ai c'est
tourcoing f7 dont j'ai cinq points f7
c'est quoi leur haine sur ton grave ça
t'arrive tours 4
paris vii de la rda et var déclaré
lieuse 5 et tout reprend ses trois
arrêts ok donc il voulait pas prendre f7
il a fait tout re 4 temps qui maintient
temps qui maintient à eux cinq ans vie
c'est pas fini tant qu'ils maintiennent
qu'ils ont eu cinq en vie c'est pas fini
tant qu'il maintient ce pion on a on a
encore des chances si ce pion meurt
c'est mort parce qu'il ya des six qui
tombe derrière et c'est fini donc l'idée
des noirs c'est d'essayer de ramener une
tour en 1 h 5 ou d'une tour en c5 pour
l'attaqué mais il reste plus qu'une
minute 30 1 pour magnus
c'est loin d'être fait un que le pion
tombe
pourquoi pas qui des deux ce que je
conçois le ski les premiers doutes on
prend des deux tours france et 3 et le
pion c3 qui tombe ça semble être le
problème un côté côté blanc il fait roi
à 6 peut-être à 4 pour bloquer un peu
tout ça il a fait g4g 4 c'est aussi
l'idée d'enlever le pion de la troisième
rangée pour surtout reprend ses trois
plus faire sur attaqué ce pion
si le truc quoi donc g4 joué et bien
joué d'ailleurs il va falloir faire tous
rêvent de tourcoing f7 s'il le peut il a
joué des 5 avec les noirs fr.fr roigé
trois tours f2
je pense qu'à mettre l'om est situé le
ranger 3 quand tu te rends tout repenser
3 sur échec et on rêve de toute façon tu
peux pas preum's étape à tours 3 il a
fait à 4 mais attendez b prend 1,4 il
veut quand il veut cavaliers des deux
quarts aile et prend des deux tours
prend des deux rives tour à deux alors
tour à deux ils clouent le pion à et il
menace sur points à 4 échecs mais si les
noirs jouent à trois ils menaceront
peut-être des tours b 8 tours prend b3
ou genre de choses c'est assez chaud il
reste 46 secondes pour les deux joueurs
maxime qui essayent de la défendre et il
se prend à trois breaks maxime comme je
disais un vraiment été décevant dans les
tournois sur internet à tourbes et 8 il
va ya voir carey liste est mécanicien
croix b 5 1 voilà qui prend 17 bon mais
là il ya aussi des tours prend 2,5 qui
rôdent cavaliers des deux cas il prend
des deux tours prend des deux tours
france et 3 ouais non ça va être fini
alors dans le dans l'autre match comme
je vois que c'est une comme je vois
qu'il ya une pause ya 6 4 donc ça fait 9
5 en termes de victoire est là dans la
partie de maxime ça semble être ça
semble être compliquée pour le joueur
français qui a aidé 2 qui est pro d2 il
veut tout reprend à 3 oui mais il ya à
roye b cette tourbe et 4,3 à huit tours
à quatre ça c'est l'idée est là de
suiveux tour à 6 3 des 5 tours à 5 3 des
5 tours des cas 3 ces six tours c-53 ses
cinq tours des deux tours 5 ces perdants
donc il va faire tour des quatre échecs
maintenant aller tout reprend g4 après
mais là il ya tour ces cinq noms
tour des quatre et c'est exactement ce
que je vous disais roi c6 et tout
reprend 1,7 ouais parce que tour ses
cinq tours des deux tours 5 c'est mort
maintenant l'idée c'est qu'il veut tour
c7 et tour 17 c'est pas fini les gars
c'est hyper chaud il ya une minute 22
pour maxime 55 secondes pour magnus
est ce que magnus val pépon j'ai envie
de dire ce que tout reprend 17
maintenant il ya le pion dépassé au
maximum qui trouvent des ressources
qu'est-ce qu'il est fort en défense il
est impressionnant
roy ses 6 17 je pense que ça va tenir ce
coq et l'ordi donne droit à six mais je
comprends même pas le coût donc je pense
croit ces six des sept qui a aidé cette
tour 17 tours ces trois tours fc est et
c'est nul
alors attendre 17 il dit quoi à 17 ya
tour g8 encore et on n'a pas le temps de
faire des huit échec terrible terrible
tour g8 auquel horreur à temps mais du
coup on peut peut-être faire tour c'est
7 1 et tours cc3v six tours c-53 ces
cinq des sept qui a aidé cette tour 17
tours j'ai quatre échecs ces perdants
il peut pas prendre ces 5 et 6 fait 17
maintenant il ya tout reprend j'ai
quatre échecs tout reprend g4 et roy
prend ses 7 qui arrête le pion donc il
va devoir jouer tour b 4 échecs tourbe
et cinq tours prend dé 5,3 prend b 5 des
7 tours prend gk3 bouge attendant on va
mettre ses la ligne de l'ordinateur qui
est en train de calculer je pense ouais
ça s'est perdu
ça c'est bien connu dans le milieu c'est
foutu ah ah merde ça c'est bien connu
dans le milieu assez terrible c'est
terrible ça perd de partout tourbe et
quatre tours ici prononcer ces horribles
il a tellement bien défendu alors est-ce
qui peut tenter c4 et français 4 et 7
haye avait tour des 5 le retour assez
horrible il va devoir rentrer dans cette
finale mais elle est perdante
je pense ce que les deux pions lier son
passé terrible pour pour maxime quand
même c'est exactement la position qu'on
avait vus c'était la vanderbilt à une
variante humaine en fait est là le
problème c'est que va-t-on va venir e4
laura va s'approcher des pions et et ça
va en est terminé des espoirs du joueur
tricolore alors il va essayer quand même
de faire un truc de marloux c'est de
bloquer droit mais le problème c'est
qu'il ya tour c'est qu'à tours sète
tours c6 et après à faire froid ces 5 3
des 5 et maxime va abandonner à hockey à
temps il veut faire maintenant le blocus
mais non il n'y arrive jamais à faire ce
blocus
bref quatre temps c'est qu'à 3 5 tours 4
3 6 et u peut jamais prendre le pion
terrible il va tenter quand même de
faire nul et encore des pièges mais ça
doit perdre fille ruth ja oui kasparov
qui gagne mais bien sûr petit mais oui
karecki bachirou déjà mais voilà ça ça
fait plaisir
voilà une victoire qu'elle fait plaisir
enfin des bonnes nouvelles qui tombent
alors à temps il était mal garé il était
mal mais on finirait mai en finale à
tutu n'est pas si fort
ouais je sacrifie la qualité regarde
dégage
j'ai mes pions pas assez extraordinaire
et oui et oui autoproclamé grand talent
des échecs farruggia or très fort joueur
mais bon garry kasparov 50 ans qui ne
touchent plus un échiquier qui n'a plus
la diète qui gagne le vieux a de beaux
restes
pour juste pour dire magnus à 13 ans
faisait nul contre kasparov 1 voilà le
savoir pendant qu'il le dit il ya plus
de 50 ans oui oui oui 5 ou plus de 50
ans à la retraite il s'en fout total bon
bah oui oui mais toi tu es nul non plus
je pense qu'il va être hyper motivés
pour cette partie kasparov du wifi roux
déjà futur champion du monde 57 ans à la
retraite
bon voilà enfin je t'aime plus fort que
toi je t'ai badge avec les noirs non
mais c'est beau
maxime qui défend cattan non il a déjà
fait retour ce défend pas maire attend
tour ces 8es ce qui peut qu'on progresse
l affaire est celle qui va monter un
pion maintenant il va progresser
graduellement
j'avais raté une finale comme ça en
championnat du monde des jeunes en moins
de 12 ans j'avais fait nul j'étais
dégoûté
on attend avec impatience kasparov car
le sel louis maxime qu'avoir mettre une
séance d'échec
terrible hein
terrible
en d'autres termes qui va se barrer je
vous préviens dès que dès qu'il ya un
score suffisant pour que le match de
dingue qu'on ne sarine soit pliée genre
dès qu'il ya + 5 + 6 va dire + 6 à 15
minutes on part tout de suite
suivent maxime à fond comme samassa me
fera quand même une petite pause qui
fera pas de mal et maxime qui a
abandonné ici mais bon c'est sur un 7
tours de pions et puis les pions vont
avancer la tour va partir et les pions
vont avancer le roi va s'approcher et
maxime toujours en petite forme sur
internet
hikaru qui va perdre mais quasiment
vides hier ce qui fait plaisir
pourquoi que pourquoi ça fait plaisir
n'en sais rien puisque si roy prend 2 ya
f5
je monte la variante en passant
rapidement
kasparov a gagné car le sait n'a gagné
hikaru va perdre sa vie car oui fait
tellement de mal hein quoi que des fois
je suis bon
icaro qu avec dominguez
mais belle victoire 1-2
de kasparov quand même
lorsque ça ne pour le pingouin dans la
dans la séance 2 1 + 1
espérant que ça joue pas mal
ainsi du monde ce soir
une épisode apparaît notamment de café
au gramme près la quantité de pâte ou de
légumes qu'ils avaient ingurgité brasse
et 200 g sosa donne quoi dominguez
machin sow qui a gagné ce qui est
monstrueux en 960 un champion du monde
qui a battu ce vide l'air et aronian
caruana ça a fait nul pour en gros on va
retourner sur le match de niall sarine
en bullet on va se faire tranquille un
donc dès qu'il ya un écart qui nous
semble assez conséquent pour que le
match soit plié on se déplacera
le 960 reprend à 21h35 mais moi en fait
j'espère réussir à ce que ce match là
dure un peu et faire une pause histoire
de rupture a aussi plus de monde quand
on suivra sur bitstream
on va pas se cacher c'est quand même
dommage de ne pas avoir suivi cette
partie bref c'est comme ça je peux pas
faire autrement mais bon la
programmation en même temps que cole 960
n'était pas très inspiré il aurait pu
progresser match à 16h par exemple savez
peut-être n'était plus à plus cohérent
après c'est comme ça on va avoir le
bullet qui est parti avec niall sarine
donc qui a les pièces blanches contre le
pingouin le pingouin qui a été
finalement très dominés 1 dans ce match
mial qui avait complètement raté son
début de match c'était faire tourner
deux fois mené deux fois au score et il
a réussi à revenir les deux et il a
réussi à revenir dans le match pardon
mené au score et puis il a réussi à
accélérer à prendre l'ascendant
notamment dans l'est dans les fins de
parties rapides on a pensé que que le
pingouin aurait le dessus lorsque le
temps imparti serait moindre et
finalement ni al sarine qui a très bien
répondu dans dans les dents dans ces
situations-là en réussissant à jouer
aussi vite que son adversaire
donc il a fait rock tour 1
il va y avoir des cavaliers prend 1,4
qui vont rodez vous prend au 4 x 3
qu'est ce qui va faire avec les noirs
que vont jouer les noirs ici
après prise prise d'amd 2 par exemple
à quand ivan shefer préfère d'un v6 tour
des huit essayer de s'en prendre au
centre dame 17 fouet f1 vont c'est une
position assez classique avec cette
structure avec ce décès contre eux des
ce pion c4 qui peut prendre nous pousse
à tout moment h3g 5
car le fou qui va revenir angers 6
d'accords signés al zain qui décide de
partir avec des 4b 5b et 6
éventuellement aller sa part sa part en
attaque al elle allait le roi il va y
avoir tour ces trois tours c'est un c6
je pense qu il ya peut-être d'un mât 5
aussi pour pour les blancs pour s'en
prendre option au pion à 7 ça peut ça
peut être intéressant
5 c'est si ça pousse à huy est sûre
[ __ ] izia poupée 5 enfilade
il ya quand même des fous p5 enfilade
qui peuvent traîner la dame qui par an à
5 comme prévu le pion à cette attaque et
tout s'est tu défends et il peut y avoir
des coups peut-être comme tour à tour
trois oui pour jouer fois à trois je
pensais peut-être à tour ces trois pour
foix iii mais tour à trois bien joué
foix iii maintenant attaque la dame la
tour qui va venir en c3 pour tous
protégés non parce que si vie en c3 il y
aura un problème donc finalement sa part
en échange de parts ou le pion dessin
qui va tomber et les blancs qui se
retrouve à la fin de cette mêlée
tactique avec une qualité de plus et une
tour qui va arriver ans et 7
éventuellement lampions à 5 et une tour
qui va peut-être arriver ans et s'être
rapidement alors il n'a pas encore
réussi à la mettre mais voilà ça y est
il a mais pour mettre la pression sur le
rock avec des idées deux dames f6 qui va
qui va plonger ou damas est et
maintenant il va falloir juste ramener
le fou pour attaquer il va faire dame b
8 échecs est fou c'est 8 et ça va faire
1 0 dans la section du let pour niall
sarine
niall qui prend cinq points d'avancé et
qui continue à mettre la pression sur
teigne on l'a vu il est vraiment
plus fort hein il joue de trois
catégories au dessus niall pour le
moment début de match compliqué pour
pour le joueur indien et finalement il a
réussi à mettre son empreinte sur le
match et c'est vrai qu'il pût baiba
finalement doute un glas ou andrew teng
est le plus fort mais il faut dire que
niall sarina 200 points de plus en
bullet donc ça va être un meilleur
joueur de bullet il a cinq points de
plus il est aux commandes du match
il reste un gros 22 26 minutes à jouer
mais le match pour moi
l'accueil de france ces trois peut-être
que les français 6 b prend ses six
prises c'est troyes et tours b 8 et à la
tour qui va rentrer en b2 et sarina pour
moi le match est déjà plié 1 c'est cinq
points c'est un gros écart généralement
il ya huit partis dans cette cadence
quand les parties durent un peu alors
tombé de il a peut-être peur de tours d
un pourra jouer le le mag du couloir
mais oui une différence de 5 points il
restait sept huit partis maximum ça part
et ça paraît quasiment plié tourbe et de
tous rêvent d un il doit vouloir
échanger
il a bougé le fou en f1 fou à 6 tours d
un tour prend des 1 prise d un oui mais
tours b 1
c'est le même esprit il ya le cinéma
l'autan aller il faudrait que le
pingouin puis ça peut revenir
safina en quelque chose comme 35 minutes
dans 25 minutes par dont la tour qui
vient en c2 il me reste peut-être des
tours france et 3 x 4 et un petit coup
comme g6 peut-être avec courage et ses
trois fils qui peut qui peut plonger il
ya tour c4 aussi avec tout reprend h4 ça
va les changer ça va sûrement aller
retour à 4 bien joué roy g7 maintenant
peut-être routage et prend h5 aussi y
prend le pion avec l'idée de jouer avec
tours d2 alors tout reprend à deux tours
c'est cette eia tour d 1 sur échec et
tourcoing f2 qui défend tous donc le
pingouin qui se dirige peut-être vers
une deuxième défaite dans la cadence est
compliqué compliqué pour pour le
pingouin sexy père celle là
ça va faire plus 6 alors il veut mettre
la tour en f4 c'est bien joué c'est même
très bien joué mais il va devoir subir
la poussée du pion à bon ça doit être
nul ça doit pouvoir quand même faire nul
après le problème c'est qu'il est déjà
en retard
et là il se vend autour d un tour - f2 à
il a encore cette ressource va devoir
faire tour des huit sarine pour défendre
avec le rang à schwyz
je m la tour en 17 es sur ton g4 il fera
f5 arif et tour des huit peut-être il
veut répéter un nom il veut jouer cette
finale là pendant des heures et il a
tout à fait raison parce qu'il a plus
aucun risque il est devant au score
donc s'il fait s'ils jouent ça et là il
reste 5 qui fait très mal
ouais la tag qui donne la partie c'est
terrible il joue tempo il fait n'importe
quoi
il y est plus il y est plus un le joueur
américain
il est plus dans le match trop dominés
trop derrière moins fort que son
adversaire tout simplement tout
simplement moins fort et à il n'ya le
sari nord est qui en plus la partie va
allègrement dépassé les 60 coups jusque
là on est déjà au 60e me servent à faire
une deux trois quatre c'est une partie
qui va durer encore 5 minutes à mon avis
qui va durer cinq bonnes minutes vous
allez peut-être s'il abandonne plutôt à
voir mais assez une partie qui dure
longtemps et qui dit parti qui dure 10 -
deux parties à venir sur moi j'ai deux
il veut tout revient et il abandonne
mais ça fait plus 6
ça fait plus 6 il doit rester à tout
casser cette partie calais il ya encore
une victoire de sarine et ça sera pliée
donc un match finalement on a suivi le
meilleur moment on a suivi la première
heure et demie qui était serrée après
les points sont vraiment parti
à côté il ya le sarine et le match a
vraiment perdu en intensité et en
intérêt voulait peut-être déjà dit mais
je crois qu'il ya qu une fois un match
retourne avec +4 ou +5 et encore c'était
le grand favori mvl qui avait retourné
oui après un mauvais début de match mais
alors ce que les matches sont serrés
un écart de 3 4 points est déjà énorme
la sarine était déjà favori avant le
match donc quand le favori à 4 points de
plus je pense qu'il ya absolument jamais
eu de retournement de situation c'est
vrai que voilà bon c'est un peu je pense
je pense qu'on va se quitter parle à un
moment donné et qu'on va qu'on va aller
complètement regarder à regarder le tour
à 966 vous êtes d'accord parce que bon
c'est un peu spécial non la de continuer
à suivre ce match à khiva qui va être
pliée je suis en train de jeter un coup
d'oeil à ce qui se passe mais là bon la
position est de nouveau à de nouveaux
désespérée pour tant que ça à faire plus
cette paille à karlsson kasparov en plus
ça reprend dans un quart d'heure mais je
pense je pense qu'on va on va suivre
cette partie jusqu'au bout et a et 6 à
+7 on filera on filera côté kasparov
parce que quand même la scea saharien il
ya un trop gros écarts il ya un beaucoup
trop gros écarts j'étais en train de
regarder pour pour changer mais ouais il
ya sept points sept points d'écart
ouais il est en tant qu d'art et essai
comme souvent un format très long et
match finalement qui tient pas ses
promesses ça a duré quatre heures et
finalement il n'y a pas eu de climax
c'est le début de match aurait été
intéressant mais si le début de match et
la fin de match avait été proche d'un
sari n'aurait gagné après deux heures de
match
finalement bilan est finalement leurs 45
deux matches qui restent un peu une
intéressante ce qui est ce qui je
trouvais dommage
maintenant bravo à sarine un qui mérite
complètement sa victoire qui était bien
plus fort andrew temps qui n'a pas
démérité
demain on suivra un autre match je vais
vous dire quand même ce que ce sera
avant de partir et je vous enverrai leur
aide de toute façon je vais quand même
vous dire ce que je sais si je trouve
rapidement
quel est le deuxième match
je pense que ça doit être alors attendez
ce qui suivent
est-ce que sur la page office et sur la
page officielle n'ya pas c'est quand
même compliqué
ok c'est à rooney riga ici qui est très
dangereux contre du cash match qui peut
être plus serré que prévu
deux joueurs indiens qui vont
s'affronter demain à 18 heures on suivra
ça tranquillement mais donc y aura match
demain dimanche et lundi
et ce sera pareil la semaine d'après ça
va enchaîner
de la même manière
être gay beaucoup moins fort donc on se
retrouve dans quelques secondes en
réalité sur bitstream attendait ne
bougeait pas il va y avoir le raid qui
va qui va partir rapidement et à et a
tout de suite quoi et bravo encore année